nickel nickel prêt pour cette 33 du tas
de style donc on a de belles affiches
aujourd'hui Mathieu on commence
j'ai suivi un peu ton test stream là
depuis deux jours on est hyper content
du plateau quand même ça fait plaisir de
voir le plateau comme ça clairement
mais pour plusieurs raisons déjà je
mettais toujours dit
qu'on trouve qu'il y a trop nul tu fais
venir des gens moins fort il y aura plus
de gains
ça marche toujours et en plus c'est les
genoux franchement le casting est bien
fait parce qu'il y a tous les genoux
qu'on voulait voir donc ça fait plaisir
de les avoir et on voit quand même
qu'ils sont un peu naïfs les petits
jeunes pour l'instant je pense à vous
caisse
la mauvaise partie
mais bon tu vois c'est l'expérience quoi
ils sont ils ont à peine à 18 ans et
il joue contre les meilleurs joueurs du
monde donc ils sont ils sont un peu
nouveau dans le cycle donc c'est c'est
en tout cas
oui c'est un peu la première fois qu'on
les voit tous ici et franchement moi je
trouve que c'est assez excitant de voir
tu vois tu vois bon bah tous les
monstres unding etc et tu vois les goûts
cash
erikasi
Kemar Prague enfin toi tout en même
temps quoi c'est cool
et il avait quelque chose
cette année d'ailleurs j'ai inversé de
ligne je me suis pris un coup donc je
sais qu'il peut gagner rapidement mais
c'est quand même il est moins fond blanc
ouais il est plus plus positionnel j'ai
l'impression plus conceptuel que que qui
peut te mettre du coup quoi
donc la partie au moins je risque pas
grand chose mais ouais en plus fantasque
vous cache c'est encore différent ok
c'est beaucoup d'énergie de calcul naïf
il y a très naïf d'ailleurs je conseille
j'ai commencé la partie
ok je les jeux trois fois donc la seule
que tu as commenté où je m'étais fait
défoncer quand il était il avait 14 ans
je pense à l'époque comme ça
et depuis je l'ai joint cette année j'ai
fait nul et je l'ai joué l'année
dernière je suis à plus 4 c'est nul et à
chaque il m'a retourné un truc avec une
minute compte 10 j'étais fou mais ouais
le mec il faut le battre plusieurs fois
moi j'ai pas réussi mais toi le style de
je le sens moins propre à de sa torov
par contre il a un style dégueulasse
mais qu'est-ce qui joue bien
il est il est assez efficace je trouve
et j'en ai joué beaucoup en fait dans le
tournoi c'est drôle
non c'est vrai il a joué à niche je
vends une forêt c'est réglé ici rapporte
c'est quoi ton score
il avait déjà 2700 mais bon c'est quand
même
j'ai perdu guéri j'ai perdu mes finales
complètement nul au bout de 6h ça m'a
énervé car on a juste joué dans un
tournoi en ligne donc ça compte pas
vente forêt j'ai fait nul mais il était
jeune il y a ici nul rapporte je joue
deux fois j'en ai perdu une et une nulle
et la nul j'étais à moins 7 j'ai
sacrifié tour de cavaliers enfin j'ai
trouvé toutes mes pièces ça marchait pas
du tout j'ai fait perpète
et Prague je les joue
trois fois ou deux fois
j'aurais dit deux une défaite une nulle
pas beaucoup de victoires
et deux fois
mais j'avais été moins bien dans
l'ouverture je m'étais pris une prépa
sur une Enzo et après je l'avais
retourné j'étais même son autre gagnant
et je l'avais laissé échapper un coup et
on avait fait nul
non mais c'est hyper important de les
jouer quand ils sont jeunes c'est quand
je regarde
je le garde en tête j'en parle souvent
cette bonne guerre
de 1700 c'était mon studieux quoi déjà
mais
je l'ai recroisé dans une boîte de nuit
disons plus tard et on a reparlé les
médias je me rappelle qu'il m'avait
proposé nous j'avais pas aimé tu vois
mais c'était nul toi et j'avais souffert
j'ai fait à perdre après il m'avait
complètement dominé la finale légale
normal donc on a des beaux cheveux
du monde contre un challenger
contre lui le match
et puis une chance sur deux
pour l'instant super frein à partir
vraiment je vous conseille tous de la
revoir c'était vraiment super et hier ok
ils ont pas trop compris la prépa enfin
les deux la position est juste trop
compliqué peut-être pour des humains il
était sans doute même un peu moins bien
bizarrement et après par contre il a
dominé il a finale on pensait qu'il
allait la gagner
et il y a eu un petit coup que j'avais
proposé dans le l'industrie c'est un
petit tour à 7 tu sais à la place de
manger H6
juste l'instant et bon un peu de hasard
aussi des fois mais mais ici en fait je
pensais à ça à la place de manger H6
parce qu'en fait louer donc je sais pas
si tu veux
et tu fais ton assiette autour d'abord
je sais pas trop quel est l'intérêt
quelle est la différence votre idée
c'est que je vais faire un SMIC
et bah ton B7 est à 7 et même je vais F4
en fait enfin juste quoi
et en fait tu fais quoi 37e
[Musique]
manger une fois quand même parce que
j'ai envie de manger
et puis même pour B7
il pensait plusieurs fois que qu'il
était foutu mais il était content
d'avoir bien répondu à la fin ce qui est
vrai d'ailleurs
mais ce que j'ai compris de son
interview c'est que Ding pensait être
gagnant après le 40 après le contrôle de
temps il a réussi hyper longtemps en
fait il s'est rendu compte à ce moment
mais ça ça le prince et que nous on sait
pas on n'a pas la barre
qui s'est dit je suis gagnant et en fait
c'est clair
et secouer la tête il disait enfin tu
vois et regarder les quatre pions
en plus il a plutôt bien joué parce que
la finale en fait
bon j'ai suivi un petit peu à la fin
pour cette comprendre parce que j'ai mis
l'ordi à la fin et apparemment le coup
le coup qui lui a fait perdre en fait
c'était bon j'avance
[Musique]
pas en fait c'est tour à cet apparemment
quand l'idée c'est que une fois qu'il
fait tour à 7 et ben il a réussi à
parfois M6 pour la tour là et faire un
blocus sur casema
[Musique]
si tu empêche le coup de venir ici moi
je comptais peut-être genre ranger 5
essayer de faire H6
j'avais regardé un peu il me semblait
que tout était nul mais oui ce qui
sortait qu'il a pas posé le plus de
soucis parce qu'on a passé en fait tu
auras 7 3 G8 c'est le seul coup mais le
problème c'est que bon il ajoute un pot
ce qui me semble que le coup que j'avais
vu c'était tour d'essayer en fait qui
empêche tous les deux déjà
mais j'en parle bien tu veux quoi je
pense que je pousse hein
garder les cases d'habits c'est les deux
c'est ce que j'avais cru comprendre mais
c'est dur de comprendre en fait tout ça
tu vois c'est hyper compliqué quoi
comment ça marche en fait les parties
ont déjà commencé le flux vidéo qu'on
t'envoie il est en différé c'est ça le
flux vidéo est le plus parti aussi en
fait là à partir
mais
dans maintenant 4 minutes et dans la
partie vont commencer tu vois avoir les
gens arrivent sur la caméra tu vas avoir
tu vas avoir les parties commencées
voilà on a juste un quart d'heure de
retard surtout si tu veux c'est bien que
le fond pour la caméra aussi bon ce qui
paraît logique sinon
c'est clair c'est clair non mais le but
c'est quand même que des batteries donc
c'est à la caméra sur la position
[Musique]
quoi donc
le moyen tricher c'est s'il y en a
quelqu'un sur place
mais du coup bon après bon quelqu'un
veut tricher c'est un peu dur des fois
de passer après je sais pas si sur place
on doit avoir des détecteurs comme ça je
résume que oui
je pense que les normes sont juste en
face
un spectateur plutôt d'ailleurs
mais bon ok après
dans ce tournoi
bon moi j'ai envie de dire qu'ils sont
tous la clean
Macron
je peux vous montrer sur le sur le sur
le stream
match donc on a on a rapporté
on a carwan avant forest
dans l'ouverture il se fait prendre
après l'autre jour mal et en fait il
obtient rien ouais
[Musique]
ça ça peut être très cool
c'est finalement
ta position et enfin moi je vois un
élève qui me fait l'imbécile je
m'engueule quoi
peut-être dans la dans les stats il y a
plein de fois où dans mes 6 qui donne
une structure aussi pourrie est un
mauvais trajet une nouvelle idée sur la
radiologie qui avait l'air quand même
assez pourri il a réussi quand même être
mieux
on a quoi d'autre goûter à chef de cet
or donc ça c'est intéressant ça c'est la
revanche de de la fameuse partie qui a
coûté le titre Aladin aux Olympiades
[Musique]
donc dure pour lui parâme apparemment il
a annoncé qui comme il a été invité en
dernier moment il s'est préparé qu'avec
les noirs
ok
mais il a pas eu le temps maintenant tu
imagines on te dit tu vas jouer le
tournoi
après après
moi qui
qui
se passe tu as vu les stats mais il a
été 5 fois 2e de ce tournoi il a jamais
gagné
intéresse est super solide qui est
meilleur a fait une pour moi une non
partie
[Musique]
du jeu solide il a joué actif et
vice-versa et ici à rognan alors ça tout
peut arriver à ça ça peut être du grand
n'importe quoi ouais et c'est l'avantage
de ce casting il y a que des rondes
intéressantes
et que des jeunes qui veulent gagner en
fait qui veulent progresser et qui tu
vois et il y aura pas de petites nulle
rapide je pense
nulles
avec les morts
quand tu es moins fort quand on
adversaire que tu as les blancs tu peux
dire vas-y je joue un truc solide et je
fais juste nul en fait mais là quand tu
vois un rapport par rapport et ben je
pour gagner Carona il va juste pour
gagner goûter
McDo va voir
après le prince
avec les Blancs
c'est improbable à partir alors là c'est
censé de commencer non
on va revenir un peu sur les parties
donc là nous on a toujours rien donc on
va sûrement vous montrer la caméra avec
les joueurs qui sont en train de
s'installer les joueurs qui sont
quasiment tous frais on va Abdou qui
s'installe toujours classe hein
par contre c'est pas un marrant ah oui
il a l'air hyper sérieux
avec sa maman
je t'envoie en face ouais c'est une
maison sans rien hein
[Musique]
le stream commence je perds toutes les
caméras j'en ai plus que trois alors
comment ça ça m'énerve quand on me dit
tu m'as appelé tocrate 333 c'est quoi
c'est un Twitter
c'est pas c'est pas ça non
[Musique]
j'en ai peut-être quatre
je sais pas si tu veux parler sur le
chat on est trois attends trois ok bah
écoute je vais te changer
les gars je suis chaud motivé j'ai le
chat à portée de main je peux répondre
donc n'hésitez pas à poser des questions
ok
c'est une surprise peut-être non ah bah
oui parce que normalement ça attendait
le catalan
je l'ai pas vu jouer d'en avoir des
parties en ligne Mathieu avec de Théo
c'est mieux
et le Londres il l'a fait avec Kelly 3
qui est 6 inclus d'ailleurs j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était plus malin de
d'inclure c'est de coups d'ailleurs
pourquoi mais ils ont déjà une partie
non je pense que
j'avais une partie que j'ai commenté
où il avait joué un truc et la partie
c'était genre C5 3
tu sais il avait juste le truc avec
6 d'imbé 6 food D6 il avait fait un truc
un peu nouveau avec Dame B6 il faut des
six
ça me dit un truc et
après ça
Magnus tu dis qu'il va avoir une petite
idée donc là il doit sonorer quels sont
les parties qu'il a joué récemment sur
le Londres
qu'est-ce qu'il a en stock où est-ce
qu'il peut s'en prendre son adversaire
en gros c'est ça
[Musique]
va être il avait commencé à jouer le
Londres Magnus un moment et d'ailleurs
j'ai joué le Londres à un moment même où
j'ai pas de France et en fait il avait
fait une session d'entraînement et des
parties d'entraînement avec cramique et
cramique avait plein d'idées sur la
Londres ok ok ils ont commencé à son
équipe à s'intéresser au Londres
était passé à la maison
peut-être qu'un jour je ferai un autre
truc dessus mais je le traduirai pas
c'est sûr
on me demande pourquoi
je peux répondre tu veux ça t'intéresse
ou pas pourquoi cavalier 3 là déjà en
plus c'est des cas de cavaliers 6 donc
si tu fais fouf 4
tu laisses les insec
des 5
et là soit dame B6 ou tu peux soit
donner B2 soit D600 c'est ok pour le
noir
et même si tu reviens sur D4D
si je vous joins le Londres moi je vous
conseille non reviens du coup au premier
coup
F4 en fait c'est 5 ici c'est fort
la ligne supplémentaire c'est qu'il y a
E4 qu'il faut connaître ici qui est pas
bête l'idée c'est de jouer c'est une
ouverture inversée avec un temps de plus
OK et l'idée c'est que si tu fais le 3
mais en fait là j'ai le droit par manque
de jeu puis on prend des quatre puis on
prend des cartes et c'est une carrocane
ici sortir le fou et des fois faire F6
pour contrer le 5 il y a même du G5
et donc ça c'est assez malin comment
deux coups
j'ai des élèves qui jouent au long de
leur conseiller de mettre le cahier
dans le live dans la game
il a je sais ça que 3
ok qui est ici c'est le grand coup mais
c'est pas de le seul coup je crois il me
semble vraiment que la dernière fois il
avait quand il s'était joué et dame
tu prends un Kilian québécente
Christian Bauer il y a hyper longtemps
ce que tu as dit marche en fait on donne
le pion pour jouer en fait
on va manger peut-être on a fait exprès
de donner les deux pions pour ranger à 6
et à la fin de 7 ans et il m'a expliqué
ça alors moi je sais plus j'ai perdu en
16 ou 17 coups cette partie ici
[Musique]
OK
et là la nouvelle façon de jouer c'est
plutôt cahier des deux
avec pour idée sur dame B6 ça t'a dû
voir il y a des parties récentes tu me
prends c'est 5
en 2017 je pense qu'on est joli je t'ai
complètement gagnant avec les Blancs
j'ai fait nul mais
maintenant le coup à la mode pour le
noir c'est une partie d'Alpha zéro qu'on
stock fiche d'ailleurs
après lui joue plutôt le 6 normalement
dans mes souvenirs il a joué quoi
[Musique]
un truc
si tu fais fout des 6 je peux prendre un
C5
et en fait j'ai pas joué ces trois pour
pouvoir jouer il faut prendre ses 5 C4
vite alors faut des sites il faut des 5
oui j'ai fait une vidéo je mentionne
cette idée mais c'était pas exactement
la même pause
vous décidez aussi l'idée fou G5 que
j'ai joué avec le pion en C7 et le pion
E2 donc c'est pas exactement la même
pause l'idée c'est de 4 en un coup donc
ça c'est pas pareil comme j'ai déjà joué
trois ça marche de temps
c'est hyper important parce que
ça aurait beaucoup moins d'impact parce
que du coup plus tard avec les 6 quand
je mange là
et moi dans mes souvenirs la partie ça
avait été d'un de 6 tourbé un Fodé 6 la
dernière partie entre eux standard
ça fait plusieurs jours que j'ai
toujours ce bug à chaque fois il m'a
fait
5 d'en prendre
à trois normalement comme ça l'idée des
blancs
en fait essayer d'éliminer le pion
ensemble et de prendre de l'espace quoi
simplement et justifier le fait qu'on
est pas joué au C2 en fait c'est comme
jouer un gambidame couleur inverse des
fois le Londres et sauf que tu as quand
même vachement de temps d'avance ouais
donc tu sais des fois le camping
là dis toi c'est ça avec un étant
l'avant donc tu peux être un peu mieux
c'est pas bête on nous demande comment
trouver ma vidéo sur fodécis et fouger 5
elle est sur Youtube c'est quand je
reviens sur le tournoi que j'ai gagné à
Barcelone en 2021 enfermé
allez on fait un petit tour de stade on
va voir un peu ce qui se passe alors
gooche Abdou on a bon là on a la
position bien connaître je pense Mathieu
non pas trop mais par oui non c'est un
peu
en fait les quatre ça a été le
répertoire de Magnus les deux dernières
années en championnat du monde de
glycératine
et il joue en gros une catalane où il a
su échanger et l'idée en fait il fait
toujours pareil il fait dame 7 tour D8
il va prendre en C4 je C5 et dire ok je
suis un peu moins bien mais je m'en fous
en fait
et les parties de mais d'ailleurs c'est
Magnus la jouer quand il était champion
du monde là il y a un mois
donc ça c'est hyper solide parti va être
peut être un peu chiante c'est toujours
un peu mieux pour les blancs mais c'est
très très solide donc c'est là à mon
avis on va pas y passer trop longtemps
le mieux préparé sur l'italienne au
monde
[Musique]
maintenant c'est le coup principal
de montrer ça tous ces élèves ce qui est
pas bête du tout en fait à 5
l'avantage c'est que les Blancs n'ont
plus l'idée de B4 A4 et prendre de
l'espace mais le défaut c'est que tu
menaces plus cavalier à 5
si tu faisais assis à la place juste
pour expliquer
3 ou à 4 plutôt à 4 d'ailleurs à haut
niveau
A5 c'est le nouveau coup et c'est très
fort torrent donc là il a deux petits
roc donc Magnus a joué H6 je peux pas du
monde
tu te rappelles tu l'as vu non
[Rires]
en fait le défaut de petit rock c'est
que tu peux laisser des ventes à base de
Fougères 5 mais qui sont en ce moment
plutôt bien pour les pour les noirs à
base d'âge 6 x 4
et en fait tu peux
faire G5 en fait qui peut faire peur OK
il y a plusieurs plans mais le plan le
plus de la mode c'est genre cavalier H7
pour jouer à 5
ou bouger le roi
après des fois les Noirs perdent en
temps d'ailleurs peut-être ici c'est
plus précis de je foi à 7 d'abord
d'ailleurs ça c'est full mentionner il
faut à 7 c'est souvent une idée pour pas
se prendre des cartes avec tempo pour
pouvoir réagir
sans manger quoi
l'autre coup logique c'est
c'est quoi
j'aurais dire
h3g4 marche 8
[Musique]
H3
soit F5 soit un cavih6
dangereux
c'est censé être ok donc normalement
c'est plutôt H3
d'un match de dommage quoi après faut
changer
et donc du coup
après rock si je dois H3 je vais être
curieux de savoir ce qu'il va faire
peut-être un petit peu je le système un
peu à la mode avec faut aussi
on verra
où il faut à cette d'abord donc ça ça
m'intéresse pour moi
[Rires]
je propose qu'on regarde en dernier vent
de Forest parce que tout le monde en
parle
tu veux
une partie
qui bon c'est un petit arbitre parce
qu'ils ont commencé à pas mal se jouer
j'ai vu à l'époque il y avait les
tata style India là tu sais et il
s'était joué 1000 fois là-bas
donc tu vois
et rien qui sont une passe un petit peu
un petit peu
il a une grande bonne période puis une
mauvaise le fait qu'il est une vie
privée enfin il y a un moment assez
difficile et là il vient d'être papa OK
je vous donne les inside si vous voulez
savoir et donc là dans ces deux qui aime
pas le plus joué en ce moment même si
c'est une grosse ligne c'est 5 qui est
pas du tout joué au niveau
je me rappelle pas d'une partie au
niveau les Noirs
tout le monde rock au dessin
donc petite surprise mais ce qui est fou
c'est que Éric ici a toujours une heure
40 à la pendule à jeter un pot c'est à
dire qu'il s'attendait à cette surprise
après c'est un joueur qui est bien
préparé de toute façon je pense que
tout c'est fou d'être préparé partout
oui oui papa de source ah c'est sûr
c'est ma femme au pire vous l'engueuler
si c'est faux mais je pense pas que ça
des 5 mais du coup ça donne des
positions
donc on est toujours un peu mieux avec
les Blancs parce qu'on est devant
au niveau du de l'initiative parce qu'on
a le développement d'avance mais le truc
ça peut vite
[Musique]
faut jouer enfin comment dire faut jouer
rapidement faut trouver une idée rapide
sinon tu vas vite te faire égaliser les
noirs peuvent le B5 faut B7 kd7 et ça y
est ils sont pas moins bien
en développer quoi
de bêtises
en tout cas intéressant parce que
souvent aussi beaucoup d'idées donc donc
du coup c'est pas mal de voir cette
position pour voir si la position de
style Les Vans il est content d'avoir un
truc solide avec les mains après voilà
l'autre a réfléchi quasiment rien si tu
regardes là c'est le premier coup il
réfléchit je crois on regarde la le
temps par coup
donc ça paraît bizarre qu'à 6 soit une
nouveauté
donc en fait il connaissait c'est un
semis de
je sais pas si bluff esquive
je vais parler et il a joué l'année
dernière en Top 12 et
Clovis Vernet
il était complètement raide dans votre
business
en fait je me suis rendu compte j'ai
inversé les coups dans la prépa et je
vais faire genre je suis dans la prépa
il a il me dit j'ai bluffé il a joué
tempo
effectivement
tu veux pas montrer l'adversaire que ta
blender quoi parce que je comprends mais
bon là il réfléchit c'est l'inverse quoi
là il bloque à l'envers quoi
ça peut on me demande
et un petit mot sur Eline Roberts ben en
fait dans le tournoi B il y a toujours
une féminine ou deux même je sais que
j'ai déjà entraîné une féminine qui joue
au tournoi un moment mais elle ça fait
plaisir c'est une néerlandaise elle est
assez douée travaille beaucoup très très
bien préparé pour son niveau et surtout
à la c'est une chose d'attaque donc il y
a si vous allez voir la partie contre
iron Lamy elle a tout envoyé donc c'est
il y a vache à lire je sais pas qu'on en
pense oui c'est la grande sœur de Prague
non
et oui qui joue pas mal 2400
[Musique]
alors
je suis pas sûr à 100% mais je me
demande si rapporte ta page de G4 ici
une fois
ou dans un truc très similaire
avec le pion à 3 je suis quasiment sûr
qu'il a joué j'ai cassé
c'est pas un coup qui qui m'étonnerait
un venant de mon rapport c'est un genre
qui est très fantasque quand il adore
ses positions
assez cool même complètement
[Musique]
il aime encore quand c'est le bordel
mais
son gros défaut c'est qu'il s'emmerde
quand tu vois sa tête il est déprimé à
chaque interview c'est horrible
pourquoi c'est pas entièrement mixte les
échètes on a répondu mille fois à cette
question et d'ailleurs c'est mixte
mais si tu sélectionnes en classement il
y a pas de joueuse dans le top niveau
c'est tout dans le top 100 il a même pas
une quoi
grande grandes études en Chine et non
mais celle-là ils ont joué trois coups
donc on va pas voilà
donc ils ont
aussi Nino d'un de ces deux
c'est une recommandation récente dans un
livre je sais plus lequel que j'ai
feuilleté c'est pas le coup principal un
dessin qui est clairement le grand coup
c'est l'ancien coup D5 et le nouveau
coup D6 avec l'idée de jouer sur les
cases noires je pomme pour E5 et là tu
as répondu de tempo F3 ce qui est pas
très bon signe quand tu veux surprendre
ton adversaire mais que
tu as failli
donc B6 pour moi c'est un peu bizarre
il me semble le coup
[Musique]
à la place de décises et jouer dame 8
qui était une ligne un peu marrante avec
l'idée d'empêcher fouger 5 et cavalier 4
et il y avait une autre idée à base de
la 5 mais sur F3 je faisais des 6,5 donc
moi j'avais la même avec un temps de moi
la dame est mis on le sait que 8 ans
mais le défaut c'est des fois tu peux te
prendre fougé 5 dans la partie il faut
qu'il fasse gaffe à pas se prendre un
fou G5 et te retrouver Chloé et pas
pouvoir vraiment t'en sortir
pour moi c'est presque une menace
autre chose
mais
souvent si ça marche
ok ça va être intéressant ça ça peut
être un gros fight hein
j'imagine son idée de jouer c'est 5 mais
visuellement il y a pas trop de raison
que ça égalise du moins pas complètement
pour ça bizarre
je sais pas parce que
j'ai vu la même
case noir
c'est ça parce que en fait elle est
passée noire même un échange en C5 si je
suis vite faut F4 31 j'ai un trou en D6
OK et donc il nous reste une partie donc
on m'a dit c'est une grosse nouveauté
dans le sens
j'ai des bases une base qui est un peu
mieux que celle-là
bon juste pour que tu saches sur ma base
à moi il dit 2400 francs cavaler ce 6
1800 fois 7 et bon faut aussi une seule
fois donc
pas la même base mais mais quand même
voilà on voit quand même que un bon
joueur et en fait ce qui compte c'est
que j'ai une base de parti de l'ordi
donc de bons
voilà
c'est ça il est parti
j'en ai parti
les humains non c'est une nouveauté pour
les humains mais pour être ordinateur
apparemment non non c'est pas nouveauté
pour les humains
qui l'a joué
il y a 80 parties en fait par
transposition parce qu'on commençait par
F5 OK
par contre ouais on va pas se mentir
c'est une petite surprise
il ne connaît pas a priori la position
donc du coup ça peut être quoi l'idée à
ton avis
c'est pas un coup pour l'instant il n'y
a plus un conséquatre
comme ça
[Musique]
mais ok c'est chaud
dessin animé
et dans la partie la gendarme 2 qui est
logique
les défauts de F5 il y en a deux c'est
la case de 5 la case F4
mais
c'est intéressant
s'installer sur le case noire ici avec
les pièces et bon après l'avantage
d'abs5 aussi c'est qu'on contrôle bien
la case de 4 et puis on peut des fois
après rock balancé j'ai 5 G4 et répartir
à la rue
donc on va y avoir des trucs
mais après
moi j'aime bien parce qu'il a toujours
des idées quoi
dans la base ce qu'il y a eu il y a eu
des fois 7 ou 7 jours ça se voit que
c'est pas l'idée
c'est
3 rock
c'est cette pause
mais oui il y a du G5 d'ailleurs
je sais pas
mais visuellement c'est un problème
visuellement ça me fait pas trop toucher
tu vois d'avoir des trucs quasiment de
partout
mais bon tu vois que par exemple qui est
ben dans l'idée vous voulez faire pour
contrôler les gaz noirs
comment je pense que je ferai cahier des
7 d'abord mais oui j'ai 5
avec tempo
et du coup
du coup avoir quoi
ça a l'air écrasant pour les blancs
alors je pourquoi
note d'été pourquoi ça serait écrasé
pour les cases
visuellement tu vois tu as le pion
isolant de 5 mois si jamais je mange ici
mais j'ai pas de
pion
je pense qu'on va reprendre un pion et
bien
le problème des blancs c'est qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire de ce foutient tu as
raison
parce que
je sais pas à quel moment mais tu vas te
prendre 5 par l'idée de de l'enfant
[Musique]
a été poussé ok non mais oui je vois ce
que tu veux dire mais ok au moins ça
agressif c'est un peu nouveau c'est
intéressant il est mieux au temps
pourquoi pas
c'est ça les noirs on laisse passe par
contre ça peut se retourner contre eux
parce qu'ils ont fait des trous donc ça
va être un vrai combat c'est à dire que
si on arrive à vraiment enlever le
contre jeu bah je pense sur cette terre
là et sur l'espace central les blancs
sont mûres en fait
les blancs attaquent parce que les noirs
sont faits sont affaiblis
c'est pas une nouveauté très très rare
pour le niveau mais c'est pas une
nouveauté et un coup de débile une
proposition un petit peu un petit peu
naïve peut-être un cavale 5 F3 ça peut
être une idée ou c'est complètement
bien sûr
est-ce que je peux jouer
un peu un peu marlou là
[Musique]
amené à partir sur une des cas donc je
sais pas laquelle et ben je voulais
essayer de cavaler complètement
et du coup
le problème c'est que intermédiaire
qu'elle va dépendre à 5 et là du coup je
sais pas à quel point ça marche puis on
prend un casque là je peux prendre un
café G3 à tout à tout moment
ça marchera pas
mais juste regarde puis on prend un
quatre c'est chaud
ici
parce que je peux manger là là
on va savoir direct sur ma question
était quoi était au-dessus
d'un machin ça marche il me semblait que
ça marchait pas bien
[Musique]
en fait j'ai fait du puzzle rush avant
le live ok
je suis fatiguée
je suis pas vraiment dans une aussi
bonne forme que toi du coup son GSX bah
ca va les prendre ici c'est là du coup
le Caval et on va te manger la pièce
mais du coup c'est drôle c'est à dire
qu'il l'a planté
et j'ai laissé tourner profondeur 45-50
pour les blondes c'est à dire que c'est
pas ça perd pas en fait c'est à dire ce
jouet pour un an c'est un peu moins bien
mais c'est peut-être
ok intéressant
mais d'après ce qu'on a vu en F4 on n'y
a pas pensé non mais F3 et d'un machin
il marche pas bah ne marche pas marche
pas très bien du coup ça veut dire que
les noirs sont contents de leur
ouverture
donc là c'est pas encore longtemps
ça paraît plus logique mais
c'est ça
c'est la même en fait avec un point de
plus c'est pour ça que j'étais parti
dans autre chose mais tu as peut-être
raison ça marche peut-être
on a la même problématique
et te dire bon
là c'est un affaire à calculer ça tu as
tout compris tu peux manger là manger là
[Musique]
je vais défendre mon foot tu me laisses
sinon
après est-ce que tu
des fois je peux même jouer
ok donc il a pas joué dans tous les cas
confortable d’apprendre
du coup je suis obligé de bouger
[Musique]
je me disais peut-être
mais bon je pense que tu as tout claqué
du coup pour pour garder d'un point de 4
[Musique]
je trouve ça sympa
je pense
qui a duré très peu de temps quand même
je m'en souviens c'était
cool
tu m'avais joué une idée que tu avais
sur la
merde ouais bon
je t'ai donné une pièce tu me l'as rendu
et mais j'avais trop de sur moi tu m'as
rendu la pièce
donc tactiquement j'ai une pièce quoi et
3 compris tu me l'as rendu en un coup et
oui j'étais tellement mal en fait que ça
suffisait mais mais belle partie je m'en
souviens encore une ici
et
j'ai rejoint un peu la même là
maintenant j'ai une nouvelle ligne sur
le dessus sur ton jeu plus celle là
parce que celle que je t'ai joué elle
est elle est dégueulasse elle perd
quasiment en ligne en fait je crois
et j'ai 4 G5 qui avait l'âge 5 ans
et
en fait j'ai revu la partie 150
parce que j'ai joué un grand maître
hongrois peut connaître un Gabor je sais
pas quoi là
il a joué F3 mais du coup est-ce qu'il
va vraiment je sais si
Mathieu
pense que si tempo avant de t'as noter
que prendre F ça marche pas je pense
genre C6
ouais mais ça tu peux avoir peur de fou
genre
[Musique]
c'est de reprendre de dés
ouais pour en fait attaquer le flou et
menacer des quatre et du coup le fou il
est enfermé mais
après bon est-ce que si on va vraiment
vraiment dans nos conneries pourquoi tu
fais avec toi et je te dis bah vas-y bah
bouffe et moi je te bouffe là
et bon courage je laisse quand même des
trucs
peut-être juste
en fait c'est que
il faut faire attention comme après
j'imagine que votre forest il doit être
encore dans la préparation donc c'était
Nagui d'abord merci Yuma
mais on arrive on a atteint la position
avec un ordre de coups improbable et
la pièce mais il y a de me prendre des
caté
[Musique]
en fait je sais pas
reviens
ici avec les Noirs si je fais juste fou
F7 ou F7 bref 7 d'ailleurs c'est plus
logique
je te prends là et puis ça va quoi
ok je suis un peu mieux avec les noirs
ah non c'est ça
après il réfléchit c'est bizarre parce
que
après ce qui peut se dire qu'il y avait
les F6 droits F7 c'est pas la fin du
monde
[Musique]
mais ouais c'est pas non plus la fin du
monde notre problème
ou assise mais ces 6 me paraît plus
logique
mais après peut-être que je dis de la
merde
non
OK
[Musique]
ça c'est une potion l'avantage c'est que
je connais bien
que tu peux montrer
tu as la caméra
c'est une idée stratégique hyper logique
l'idée c'est qu'on force qui est ici
parce que sinon il y a 6 ans prises et
l'idée c'est de jouer
la structure alors il y a une partie
très connue tu connais évidemment entre
amande et
Carlson amande où il y a juste ce plan
exactement la même avec l'idée d'Ama 3
il est noir il faut qu'il joue hyper
dynamique
ça peut être à 5 ça peut être cahier des
7 pour E5 faut pas qu'il se fasse visser
sur la casser 5 en fait les blancs parmi
leurs rêves c'est damma 3 qui a eu des
deux qui est béton
OK et d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est pas
exactement la partie contre un Inde tu
peux pas tu as pas la base là
après si tu veux
mais fou B5 un des premiers à la venger
ça a été inicipé à nous contre moi il
m'avait pas pris en C6 mais ça m'avait
perturbé un peu fou
pour la structure d'ailleurs je peux te
montrer exactement à la base de fruits
cinquième coup moi j'avais joué j'avais
joué qui est ici
trop bien
je fous des trois ça me fait hyper
perturbé mais tu sais ce que c'est le
meilleur coup maintenant théorique après
faut baisser 5 ici complètement
incroyable des fous des 6 ou 7
on veut plus avoir la même position avec
ce problème
et du coup lors de coude la partie
paraît un peu plus avantageux pour les
blancs par contre c'est un peu simpliste
ce genre de trucs si le noir sont précis
ils vont égaliser donc faut voir faire
la position actuelle il réfléchit
donc un ensemble
après 17 qui font le job
OK
dans la partie là je me tire
reprendre de C par exemple comment
égalises après je me lève
sur la carte C5 tu verras après
même
[Musique]
on nous dit dans le chat de cahier
je me prends en pression peut-être que
c'est dans tous les cas dans ces cas
c'est mieux le faire direct qui est de
peut-être
non mais
je pense qu'il est au fond du trou
hier
j'étais la cérémonie ils ont rigolé un
moment et même moi j'ai parlé avec
Carlson on a parlé de l'imam pour
rigoler il s'en fout en fait
après ce qu'il a parlé 300 euros tari et
pas 300 euros près c'est juste pour la
blague et d'ailleurs dans le truc du de
l'avocat ils ont mal utilisé mal
orthographié un norvégien
ouais
mais bon
histoire là de toute façon
je pense que
c'est ça qui est drôle mais bon
malheureusement pour lui bon peu importe
peu importe ce qui s'est réellement
passé ou pas tu vois ben son nom en fait
il est attaché quoi il est
enfin je pense que ça carrière elle est
difficile quoi pour l'instant elle joue
hein
tournoi les tu vois c'est un peu plus
compliqué quand tu as une étiquette
ou pas
[Musique]
pourquoi la caméra en direct sur blanc
de jouer t'as pas il demande pas des
coups
alors la caméra
[Musique]
ce qu'on avait dit
c'est un quoi
alors
madame A3 du coup dans ma 3 et qu'avait
le 4 et on va et on va voilà notre
réponse on est quand même pas mauvais
aujourd'hui dans nos prédictions de
coups 4
tu as proposé cahier des deux
puis on prend
des 4 mais est-ce que peut-être aussi
une idée de juste manger ça que de faire
tourner
et rentrer avec la colonne C c'est pas
une idée parce que dans celle-là s'il
prend des cartes ou pas tenir la baraque
c'est facile oh [ __ ] j'en peux plus
donc du coup je pense même manger et
manger les dames et je trouve ça et
essayer de
défense et 5 et défend la dame donc
quand tu me joue un Manon ou kyd2
je peux prendre en D4 intermédiaire
parce que madame est protégé
c'est ça pour ça que les noirs sont ok
du coup je te retiens donc ça c'est
intéressant
du pion de la dame
et dire je suis un peu mieux parce que
ton fou va avoir du mal à rentrer
et si tu fais ces quatre
pardon
[Musique]
tu peux E4
et si tu me fais C4 il veut que je B3
je suis pas trop fan de cette position
je suis pas sûr que ça soit
blanc sont mieux je pense
cavalier ces trois d'abord pub B3
on me demande pourquoi qui est prendre
des cartes mauvais alors c'est juste par
principe j'aime j'avais la flemme de
calculer si il est noir pouvait pas
jouer E5
fou du coup c'est pas un truc enfin
ouais de manière un peu automatique on
regarde pas trop parce qu'on voit que ça
c'est des cookies
mais bon
le 7
OK
alors du pion c'est intéressant qu'on se
crée un pion désolé mais du coup au
niveau de la structure en blocs
et je contrôle la
et après échanger le plus de pièces
possible à mon avis il y a pas grand
chose pour les blancs
sont au milieu donc ah non il y a Prague
qui est mieux
blondes sont pas mieux en fait le foot 8
est enfermé les blancs doivent jouer sur
case noire donc ils peuvent mettre le
[ __ ] B2 ils peuvent jouer aussi le
plan par MG4 qui est G3 et je vois le
roi
tu es mieux partout en fait
et si tu me fais prendre des cinq
je pense tu n'as pas de mauvais coup
mais je reprendrai de eux
probablement
dans l'idée un peu de position un peu
comme Belloni Benko pour essayer de
casser un peu le centre quoi mais du
coup c'est vrai que B3 en fait la
structure le foot est tellement pourri
dans cette position et quasiment n'est
pas là du coup tout est ouvert sur case
noire donc c'est vrai qu'en fait on se
rend pas la tête c'est juste ça c'est
structure elle est magnifique dans le
cas précis il y avait prise aussi de
prise de sang mais
la structure et en fait ça c'est la
question quel est le mauvais fou
des blancs des blancs c'est le fouet fin
c'est le noir c'est un bon fou théorique
parce que les pions blancs sont sur
casse blanche mais le problème en fait
la chaîne de la structure c'est C4 ou B3
sont faits B3 et sinon c'est G2 se fout
peut pas l'attaquer et les blancs
doivent jouer sur 15 mois du coup ils
doivent mettre tous leurs pions sur
casse blanche pour pouvoir jouer sur
case noire donc B3 pour mettre de sur B2
ou d'ailleurs fouger 5 un jour où j'ai
quatre etc c'est pas juste je préfère
largement
[Musique]
fébrile direct
c'est bizarre de jouer les deux jeunes
ça va pas trop ensemble c'est structures
les laisser des bêtises comme ça en tout
cas pas trop tôt là c'est avec l'idée
comme on l'avait dit
on ne pose une question dans le chat sur
la position de Magnus j'imagine
on va d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est
une question il y a pas de point
d'interrogation par rapport à la finale
majorité elle dame plus mauvais fou
alors le mauvais fou c'est relatif il
est juste il sert pas à grand chose dans
sa vie c'est dans la partie de Carlson
qui parle
cavalier donc est-ce que tu as envie
d'échange d'hab c'est pas clair
mais je pense c'est assez solide
[Musique]
mais bon ouais non c'est
symétrique c'est pas grand chose
c'est très léger salut Kévin
Kevin qui avec qui on a partagé ce live
pendant deux jours
[Musique]
facile
donc Kevin qui nous a quitté hier une
heure avant la fin du stream pour aller
voir le match de foot et il a bien
raison
en quoi c'est un bon coup pour les Noirs
la rupture B3 un moment donné non je
sais pas ce qui fait qu'aller les deux
ou si je fais bête pas direct
malheureusement
[Musique]
ok bon pour l'instant
c'est le petit coup de moule le fameux
[Musique]
D4 et X4
et je prends là et si tu vas en A4 et
ben je fais échec et je prends la
c'était pas un coup
qu'il avait
juste réfléchi parce qu'il voulait
rester lignes et un parent du coup c'est
quoi le concept quand tu vas bouger le
cavalier
parce qu'il va avoir un problème sur
la maintenance
toujours pas je crois de manger cavalier
il me semble
est-ce que vous pouvez aussi c'est un
coup de
fouet
[Musique]
tu veux reprendre de quoi maintenant de
ce que ton coup est toujours perdu
mais bon faut toujours s'envoyer les
tours qui sont toujours toujours là mais
ça change rien juste que je m'en fous en
prison
j'ai pardon B2 faut prendre les quatre
[Musique]
cavaler des six je peux aussi aller
ailleurs mais tu as raison
de ce que tu veux faire
[Musique]
à partir de rien
en tout cas
il a égalisé assez facile qu'on a numéro
3 mondial
c'est ça et il a même pas eu besoin de
prendre un C4 parce que là tu as défendu
avec ta sœur
donc là il menace de prendre et défendre
donc
ça c'est vraiment Magnus si je joue
comme ça avec les Noirs ils te dis tu me
battras jamais
trop c'est pour mettre le Cameroun
c'est un peu artificiel mais après c'est
dur de trouver un plan peut-être
[Musique]
bon après c'est
en fait
dans la position avec le pion A4 c'est
le pion A6 les blancs font B4 à 4 vitres
et tour à deux pour défendre le roi
et il est parti aux candidats il y en a
eu deux il y a eu furosa rapporte et
et Carona qui perd avec les lampes
et sa structure a été avec assis donc
les Blancs avaient BK mais là on est
censé être mieux par contre le défaut de
cette ligne avec A5 donc j'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure que ça perdait un temps
mais par contre il y a fou B5 tu donnes
une case donc dans la partie là je
pouvais 5
il faut à 7 ok ça j'avais pas ça je le
connais pas
parfois assez de l'idée c'est que pas se
prendre des cartes avec tempo
on est obligé un petit peu de manger en
Descartes sinon on se prend la
fourchette derrière
c'est la partie
il a joué pour le gain clairement avec
les Blancs parce que là
pour l'expliquer ça serait jamais
vraiment fou fou parce que maintenant le
foie ça serait vraiment très fort
ça serait même une faute positionnelle à
mon avis
et
les fous comme ça et puis que c'est un
programme du cavalier par exemple on
peut je pourrais ça
[Musique]
pour essayer de moins d'échanger de fond
ok
7 son idée c'est qu'en fait c'est un
moyen de défendre le Pione 5 parce que
maintenant si tu me fais [ __ ] en C6
faut prendre ces 6 de 5 tu gagnes pas de
pions parce que
tu t'habitues tu fais ta petite
géométrie à chaque fois
alors du coup on disait à la place de
jouer
et ici hein
[Musique]
je prends le 5 et je prends un 4 et les
Noirs ont la paire de fouille aucun
souci c'est un thème à connaître en fait
on peut laisser le Pione 5 on dirait
qu'il est en prise mais en fait il y
avait quatre en prison
[Musique]
pas toujours cavalier prend puis on
prend faut prendre des 7
juste pour les gens je montre juste tes
tactique en fait vis-à-vis ici avec
échecs mais ici ça donne un avantage je
suis même pas sur quel point les quatre
je parle ok
mais du coup mon cavalier prend c'est
pas forcément
ce qu'il a fait il a joué une autre
thème que j'ai mentionné là je fous j'ai
5 à 6 et on laisse faire G5 et ce que
j'ai
et là il a joué tout va vite pour jouer
sur le centre ok non ça ça va être un
salaire ça peut être une belle partie ça
alors comme tu veux
moi j'ai vu qu'il y a eu des coups dans
la partie de carbone de Carson j'ai vu
qu'il y a eu des coups
[Musique]
on a vu trois coups depuis il a
travaillé
allez il a commencé à réfléchir quand
même
donc il a un pion de plus mais
il a une petite mauvaise structure quand
même
récupérer de toute façon je pense hein
mais bon tu reprends du coup
je regarde des trucs
4 qui est malin
si on peut
ok donc
pour B6
[Musique]
tu peux même avoir l'air bête
en B3 encore c'est ça
parce que je capte pour le prochain coup
ça paraît bizarre ce soir
ça peut faire peur
[Musique]
petit rock ici c'est clairement
candidats
[Musique]
aujourd'hui à fond n'hésitez pas à
écrire
par rapport à des positions des trucs
que vous voulez voir n'hésitez pas à
nous demander on essaiera de
avec modération c'est ça
alors vas-y donc il nous manque Éric et
si à rognon qu'on a pas du tout vu
les chômeurs sont là aussi ah ça me
rassure
donc là il a commencé à réfléchir
vraiment là il faut de
et des 7 puisqu'il menacé
donc là ils vont mettre les tours au
centre
maintenant j'ai toujours préféré les
noirs
ouais mais il y a ceux qui doivent
garder leur enfant
c'est un peu plus galère
ok bon on retourne à Magnus comme c'est
comme la partie ça alors Magnus il est
là donc du coup
il y a eu ces quatre images
[Musique]
mais
donc B3 a été joué ou D7 a gagné
c'est que j'ai pas la même position sur
un autre site
je vais
non en fait il y a c'est sur l'autre
site il y avait un bug j'avais un pion
en C5 en C4 je comprenais pas pour les
noirs
pour fb8 KD2 qui avait lieu 8
je pense qu'il y a rien du tout
dès que tu vas jouer 5
je pense
[Musique]
un jour
c'est vraiment le professionnel
je te laisse
empêche toutes les entrées ici
évidemment peut-être au coup d'avance
c'était un peu plus logique mais
pas l'empêcher pour vraiment si tu peux
jouer encore pour ça
dame B6
je m'attends pas à une position
aussi tomber 5 aussi après il a pris
hein
non mais on va on va sûrement assister à
des échanges de acompte
la seule intéressante c'est parent au
niveau des poses
on devrait moins mais du coup ça devient
symétrique
mais qui risque de ça planning un petit
peu je pense
c'est peut-être le moment
on va s'amuser un petit peu et puis le
reste pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
grande partie aussi Prague qui meurt qui
est intéressant
mais oui c'est
le seul d'ailleurs qu'un prêt avantage
le but
aller voir le B des fois oui mais en
fait quand on avait des soins le chat
qui nous aiguillé vers des parties
spécifiques du B s'il y a des parties
que vous voulez voir dans le B on peut
très très bien aller voir le B1 parce
qu'on laisse pas grand chose quand
j'avais commenté il y avait marquant qui
jouait donc j'avais
s'il y a vraiment des parties
gouvernements enlevés on peut on peut
aller voir
j'avais vu une partie comme ça alors
plus de qui vous avez vu un dépanque
avait ses 6 ça avait l'impression que tu
avais l'avantage de la paire de fin de
case blanche avec les Blancs et au final
il y avait rien eu c'était quoi
ouais j'en ai une en tête
dans la partie si il fait cavalier 5
là
il y a des six
ça marche
une petite fourchette qui va gagner j'ai
pas de coin intermédiaire
malheureusement
[Musique]
il est passé en
un thème connu dans ces positions avec
l'idée quand tu reprends maintenant je
fais qu'il prend des cinq il est noir
peuvent être mieux parce qu'ils peuvent
jouer pour C5 mais là non juste ça
marche pas donc c'est ça son piège donc
il force après il peut prendre 2e et
essayer de la structure si je regardais
mais un peu comme comme Ding a fait un
autre structure contre contre je pense
pas la même position mais c'est grave
peut-être qu'elle prend des scènes juste
alors vu qu'il va montrer aux gens d'en
prendre on n'a pas le tension le coin
tamaza parce que je reviens
et quand je prends là en fait cette
position
et comment ça te pose j'ai l'impression
surtout non
ça va être compliqué
mais du coup je reste quand même sortir
une pièce qui est des deux et du coup
pourquoi tu es mieux
il veut peut-être prendre un F6 fais
voir mais tu auras C8 je sais pas si
c'est vraiment possible
il veut pas prendre
ce que je dis dans le chat il a le droit
de le voir le piège il va faire dame
prend des 7 si il prend là
et là il y a une pièce du coup ça fait
chèque
d'avance du coup je mange de la dame
forcément
quand même pour moi parce que c'est 5 si
tu le fais tu as déjà tu as du mal et tu
es pas sûr d'égaliser
à 5 3 un truc comme ça tu as un poil
mieux
ok ça ça peut durer
ça peut dur
je vais me faire un petit tour d'horizon
alors ok en tout cas Abou qui revient
donc du coup bon clairement il y a que
eux prend aussi prend je pense un
cavaler prendre des seins que je dois je
me demande pas du tout en train de me
dire mais c'est prend il y a torcer
cette c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu peur
j'en peux plus
ok on va aller voir karwana il a jaugé 5
il a fait
le cavalier
et c'est un peu ce que vous voulez
entendre ce qu'il y a une heure 11 donc
là il a quatre réfléchi à fois F6
il veut reprendre dans les quatre
évidemment et on va prendre deux
pour pas te laisser pousser quatre
tout à l'heure et
c'est chaud c'est quoi
défendre comment j'ai tu vas rester avec
quoi à la fin
parce que sur ça je peux manger là je
peux manger là en fait
je pense que je prendrai en quatre
plutôt
pour avoir les cases blanches
pas sûr
je sais pas si pour bloquer un peu ce
pion ça c'est l'enfer à jouer c'est
pollutions
et au premier coup d'ailleurs
tu peux aussi prendre tu peux jouer 5
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
après du coup
il y a plus de problème avec est franc
maintenant parce que maintenant le frein
il me casse en ces deux cases de repli
une question
c'est quand même pas mal il faut faire
attention
le roi a force de pousser les pions et
puis on recule pas donc le roi peuvent
aussi se retrouver faible évidemment
il peut y avoir des cases faibles autour
du roi tu vois par exemple en parler de
cette structure bah en fait juste
tu as pas par exemple
[Musique]
qui se réfère
aux Espagnols ouvertes
le font aussi ce qui tient toute la
maison le problème des blancs c'est
qu'il manque de rupture ici
avec A4 là c'est dur de trouver un front
ok c'est fou
[Musique]
hyper bizarre
parce qu'il y a des coups
en dessin
de concurrent et je vois la jauge il
aime pas eux prendre l'ordi
c'est vrai que prend ça m'a l'air
naturel pour pas laisser de contre-jour
en fait de ce côté là
présente rarement sortir comme un salut
arrive mais là il a des choses plus
importantes à faire
eux prend vas-y je pense qu'il va je
baisser 5
B3
genre bcbc ouais
et en plus
peut-être que
tu es un problème pour mettre ton roi il
ajoute toroide d'abord
et ça rappelle énormément une ligne que
j'ai joué c'est sur dame C2 au 4e
si je veux plein de fois B6 je sais pas
si tu as déjà entendu parler de cette
ligne
en fait l'idée c'est que si je joue KF3
ou A3 en fait j'ai une version améliorée
parce que je joue B7 je contrôle le 4
mais le défaut il y a toujours un défaut
quand tu joues une ligne à la con comme
ça
et le défaut mais il y a eu 4 ici
c'est 5
dessins
prise
de Me surprise en descend du
E7 fois 2 rock j'ai joué ça souvent et
après tu fais des six et d'essayer de
trouver du jeu des fois les blancs
peuvent aller le chercher le fou alors
cavalier 2 était aussi possible et du
coup c'est les mêmes structures et c'est
vrai que des fois l'ordi te disait que
tu faisais des 5 € 8 en B6 ou en E5 et
c'était ok non
c'est la même schéma quoi même rupture
et même tout ça quoi
et du coup le plan ça va décide d'avoir
le foot en case noir donc soit B3 full
B2 soit fou G5 comme on disait mais
comment est-ce qu'on va se trouver la
rue pour le roi ils ont l'argument de
tes mal développé c'est ça et mon roi il
a pas de il a pas encore d'abri là
est-ce que est-ce que roi F2 c'est
complètement débile non non pas du tout
c'est pour moi le logique donc
je dis pas qu'il est bon
parce qu'en fait on a envie de trouver
la rue pour le roi mais bon faire j'ai
trois fautes les deux ça faibli tout ça
avec le même jour c'est pas forcément
une bonne pièce et
c'est pas bête après sachant que les
Noirs veulent jouer 5
alors 17 d'abord quand même pour pas te
que tu me bousilles la structure et je
veux jouer baisser un coup prochain ah
il y avait qui prend des cinq peut-être
généralement pour les pour les pour les
débutants parce que en fait
l'idée c'est que tu veux jouer
en fait pour sortir des pièces
j'ai plusieurs possibilités
c'est pas facile et puis en plus ça
c'est long et puis ça fait du sens comme
ça et en fait là donc sur case noire on
a le monopole vu que les Noirs
est-ce que les blancs à 4
tu veux jouer
mon petit B3 genre
tu fais quoi quand tu es en B4
ouais le mec fait à 4 je vais embêter
reste là jusqu'à la fin de la partie
intéressant
pour répondre en fait les Noirs les
Blancs les Noirs ici doivent jouer sur
casse blanche parce qu'ils ont en faut
de casse blanche donc B5 c'est la seule
idée c'est le seul truc pour essayer
entre guillemets de faire exploser les
quasiment et quand il fait B3 l'idée
c'est de mettre de cavalier en B6
d'attaquer le pion C4 et peut-être un
jour même de sacrifier en dessin comme
talentage développement tu peux
commencer à regarder des trucs
dynamiques
de réagir rapidement avec leur roi c'est
vrai que même
l'idée c'est qu'on se déclene le roi il
est plutôt en sécurité au niveau des
cases noires et bah brûle cavalier
sortir le fou et éventuellement
voilà on se développe et mon roi il est
il est extrêmement en fait
bien défendu en pas de problème mais
après voilà l'urgence peut-être
s'empêcher contre le B5 les noirs avec
A4 qui semble tout à fait
de la caméra c'est toujours CARSAT
je vais vous voir si j'ai une cam sur
sur Prague mais encore une fois
il faudrait d'ailleurs qu'on change de
cités et comment on change souvent c'est
chiant mais le problème en plus c'était
que j'en ai une sur deux qui marche donc
puis en plus ces caméras partent et
reviennent donc des fois ça change
celle que tu sais que j'ai pas
[Musique]
mais dites-vous que moi tout mettons la
déchets que nous pendant tout notre
échec c'est dans des salles bruyantes
comme ça
oui
en Espagne où vous étiez 10 c'est quand
même plus petit
à Majorque en fait on était en dessous
d'une boîte de nuit et on recommençait
le parti à 21h donc donc oui c'était
compliqué et sinon là aucun arrêt
j'avais fait un temps la fermer un coq
qui est pas loin d'ici où il y avait en
face chaque année c'est pareil ils sont
un oiseau il y a un voisin qui a un
oiseau et qui fait que de toutes les
trois minutes
enfin on fout quoi et sinon
sinon
je viens de voir d'ailleurs et je suis
content parce que du coup ça prouve
qu'on a compris un peu la pause
du coup tu aurais 8 je trouve vite
j'en ai fait deux
j'ai joué en Coupe de France le jour de
la Gay Pride
dans le club d'échecs de Montpellier
c'était ouf
et l'autre l'autre qui était fantastique
tu as joué en Ligue Catalogne ou pas
alors moi j'avais un club à moi je veux
pour mon cada et
quand on joue à domicile c'est
un monde cada c'est un gymnase où il y a
des matchs de foot salle
en même temps mais la porte est fermée
donc ça va mais le prince et que les
joueurs de foot quand ils ont fini les
matchs de l'après-midi il peut y avoir
les filles et les mecs et un match aux
jeunes
et là il mettait la mano d'hédios marado
marado
et j'ai la fête il commence à picoler et
oui il y avait une porte mais avec la
porte tu entendais tout et donc ouais
donc tu sais que si tu gagnais pas en
moins de trois heures trois heures et
demie tu avais la musique à fond
de finir vite
à Nîmes et à la fête foraine la fête
foraine qui est en face je sais pas si
tu vois comment le club de Nîmes c'est
au stade
de grosse stade et juste à côté d'un
grand parking dimanche et donc à la
période de l'année donc je sais pas
quelle période c'est je dirais que c'est
vers vers novembre comme ça tu as
toujours
été foraine voilà et du coup la forêt
c'est la même musique de clown qui est
non-stop en boucle et là par contre il y
a quoi de venir fou moi j'avais fait une
partie de quasi 5-6 heures l'année
dernière et je m'en souviens encore
c'était un truc de fou quoi tu avais la
musique tu sais le
beaucoup de temps
et mais quand tu pars quand tu finis
ouais je pense que c'est du pain à
partir de 6h juste
pour portable ils t'ont rendu fou mais
à Nice on avait à l'époque le club qui
est à côté aussi du stade de foot dès
que tu avais un match c'est que tu avais
par club le même jour c'était pas
possible en fait c'était non mais
c'était pas possible ça c'est un
le stade officiel quoi de tous les les
chromates de Ligue 1
et du coup c'était abusé
voilà voilà
un peu
et d'ailleurs la partie de Google qui
s'est passé plein de choses il y avait
des échanges de pièces on peut les voir
si tu veux
on s'est arrêté à cavalier le 5 c'est
prendre des 5 coups de store je disais
que c'était pas là que oui c'est plus
malin Damas 3
changer les pièces
ça a l'air solide mais est-ce que tu es
complètement égal c'est toujours le même
des bottes trop de 8
peut-être il veut que je fous à 8 pour
jouer c'est 5 un jour
une partie comme ça de K-Pop contre
l'OIT
de la connaître
comme ça
il y en a
j'en connais après est-ce qu'il peut
ouais il dit je t'empêche qu'il y ait
des deux et si tu me joue KS3 il faut
que tu calcules
parce que B5 GT en B5
mais bon
cavalier à trois
options mais bon tu perds de temps quand
même à trois tu penses qu'il va jouer à
mais bon et tu as donné le coup de case
blanche c'est pas ce qu'on recherche
ce sera ça dépend à la fin mais là j'ai
un peu non
c'est pas si simple
et du coup tu peux dire c'est pour ça
qu'il a mis la tour ah c'est qu'un jour
il veut jouer
6 F4 F6 ou quoi
pour provoquer F4 et faire F6 et
l'autre
c'est peut-être juste pour pas 140
prises
peut-être du coup je vais tourner
ok enfin
le rôle principal
de développera jamais mieux non non
ok mais ça doit être proche de l'égalité
quand même mais c'est pas simple parce
que 4 aussi qui peut être assez relou
quoi
tu parles de quel parti
on active la tour par le côté pour faire
tour à 3 ça donne un
petit cavalier B4 par exemple ça peut
moi c'est pas le truc le plus logique
mais pas attention
un petit coup de pion ça peut poser
problème
cherche une cam sur j'ai pas praxe je
l'ai pas encore
on me dit de regarder une partie dans le
challenger je vais regarder sur mon ordi
à côté
pendant ce temps là je vais voir si on a
du nouveau on a 45
pour mettre la caméra
[Musique]
et donc c'est pas très grand chose il y
a eu tous les échanges qu'on avait dit
on écrit
[Musique]
tous ces pions
de dames qui est indécis
ouais c'est un poil mieux mais
tout ce qu'on avait dit tourbé 5 26 7
voilà
[Musique]
même à 4 ça peut être un
forest qui a joué F5 G50 c'est pas 40
ans d'ailleurs
on avait parlé de ça ça
c'est vachement plus logique que
ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on retourne en
E4 sans doute maintenant
mais ok les blancs sont peut-être un peu
mieux maintenant quand même
en fait sur le long terme les cases
noires vont être parler plus forte que
la Casa et l'objectif des blancs ça
serait de jouer bon cavalier contre faut
aussi
[Musique]
un peu ça et ça ensemble et ensuite
mettre un cavalier c'est typique dans
les positions un peu de Stonewall
Mathieu
c'est pas vraiment très drôle mais c'est
compris
je suis d'accord
ok donc ça c'est quand on a enfin un
petit tour des sables pour ceux qui
viennent d'arriver
on s'emmerde un peu
les pièces sont plus en harmonie il
fasse plus simple en fait alors que les
blancs ils font encore voir où mais la
dame parce qu'il y a un vis-à-vis il
faut encore arranger quelques petites
choses
le seul problème des Noirs c'est le
cahier des 7 qui est pas beaucoup de
cases
mais tu dois pouvoir en trouver une
quelque part peut-être
B6
[Musique]
qui est
Ms8 qui avait fuite qui est intéressant
avec
ok
[Musique]
tu es contente
je sais pas si vraiment il a envie de
d'envoyer
comme ça
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps d'accord je crois que
c'est ton nom
[Musique]
attends
des trucs en 3
c'est plus ça que je voyais mais
on a quoi d'autre rapports
[Musique]
il y a un thème comme ça il a un pion de
plus mais une structure un peu étonnante
il y a un thème comme ça de
Tourcoing ainsi que il existe je crois
que Carona a perdu contre 45 je crois
que du monde de
bêtises
c'est ça la partie
croit que c'est ça
ah pas ça
[Musique]
c'est comment la ligne
je sais pas de quoi tu parles
si moi non plus je sais pas de quoi je
parle on a un problème
je l'ai plus là je l'ai plus là
mais il y a une ligne
ça me dérange pas
j'arrive plus à me souvenir de la ligne
exacte il y a une partie de il y a en
fait c'est un chat
comment ça marche
bref je sais plus laisse tomber
j'abandonne mon idée désolé
et c'était marrant parce que Carola il
avait perdu en
10 coups avec les noirs
parce que là il fait rien et après ça
qu'une fois
logique qui a été 7 héro F2
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a un bel avantage blanc
ici avec la paire de flou et plus de
possibilités en fait tout simplement
sur les Noirs
mais c'est pas forcément très très cool
donc la kawei G3 du coup ça contrôle la
clé G4 il y a plus rien du tout je
prends juste donc elle va aller prendre
je crois je vais pas de souci je pense
merci beaucoup Guilhem c'est exactement
ça que je cherchais assez
beaucoup
H300 bon coup alors mais pourquoi pas
faut deux
je pense à mon cou à quel moment
il y en a qui demande un bon coup
comment on active le flou blanc pour les
Noirs mais c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
que je B5 pour que C4
là je pense juste que les Noirs vont
souffrir ouais le fou il est pas bien
mais c'est vraiment une faute
positionnelle tu peux
même si je joue
tout le monde et si je vais enlever
cette bloque les cadavres en fait qui
des fois revient dans des sept
c'est vraiment typiquement les
production où il aime bien qu'il aime
bien Prague donc voilà après faut pas
oublier que les blancs au niveau
développement ils sont pas en arrière
vous voyez ils ont pas encore c'est pour
ça que H3 etc on va essayer d'éviter il
faut vite sortir de la pièce comment
[Rires]
j'ai
les joueurs
mais yes merci pour pour ta partie en
tout cas Guilhem
c'est le plus simple pour le blanc
et pourquoi une lettre par une lettre il
va se faire virer lui non c'est pas lui
que j'ai viré tout à l'heure
[Musique]
ça fait deux fois peut-être que tu peux
que tu peux le
le ban pour de bon et moi je sais pas
faire VIP
ce qui est pas connu pour être le plus
positionnel du circuit
c'est un peu moche parce que tout à
l'heure on en a parlé en fait de cette
case de 5 qui pourrait être vraiment
forte pour les blancs si jamais il y a
eu plus de jeux
moi je vois bien car on a gagné
[Musique]
mais je pense vraiment que le moment clé
c'est le fou prend un 5 il a pas aimé
cette pause il a dit je vais jouer ça et
solide
on va essayer de tout échanger
le rêve ça serait d'avoir un cavalier
ici contre le fou aussi et avoir échangé
les fous entre eux et le contre le
cavalier quoi ça c'est la position rêvée
quoi des blancs
et
du coup bah on va prendre le chemin
je pense ça va être l'idée de carbonara
ici un tour échanger les pièces
ce qui fait partie de sa team de second
nom c'est à dire qu'il travaille pendant
10 heures par jour pendant une période
donnée des positions
d'ouverture pour chercher des idées dans
une ouverture oui
préparateur d'ouverture
le boulot il se corrige entre eux ça
marche comme ça
[Musique]
il faut quand même pas mal réparer tout
ça
parce que
du coup là il va jeter le four
à la directe
mais je sais pas si ça remarque à
quelque chose d'avoir le droit en E1
maintenant cette position des deux
tourbéens autour des vitres de 1 j'ai
pas empêché
e tout à l'heure aussi
[Musique]
j'ai plus le F4 tout à l'heure
tu peux prendre celle-ci c'était pas
moins bien encore mais oui est-ce que tu
es mieux je suis pas sûr tu as tour C2
que tu veux pas jouer je pense la façon
c'est un vrai pas du tout vu mais
effectivement c'est un bon coup après
cavalier F5 faut voir si ce que je veux
trois du coup
non après je pense pas qu'il y ait grand
chose pour les blancs
mais le contre jeu de noir peut faire un
petit peu peur tu vois
[Musique]
en 2013 quand il y a 10 ans quand il
était remonté top 15 mondial
est-ce que j'ai été payé cher non pas
trop mais c'était pour apprendre
ça me faisait un petit salaire c'était
pas mal
c'est quand même pas n'importe quoi et
n'importe qui quoi
est-ce que c'est vrai que le secondaire
non c'est qu'il a un mec qui est bon en
informatique qui est autour de 2000 2002
s'appelle little John c'est pas une
blague
et ouais donc il l'aide pour les
ouvertures après je pense qu'on aille à
d'autres personnes mais il le dit pas
combien de temps j'ai bossé avec pour
deux ans je parle de trois ans
alors on va tourner ce salaire il est
quand même un peu molle
il a compris qu'il pouvait être moins
bien s'il a tendance
[Musique]
je ne travaille pas pour Maxime
je lis les commentaires je seconde déjà
non j'entraîne des jeunes les jeunes je
peux encore leur apprendre des choses
toi son idée de c'est vraiment pour
déséquilibrer pour jouer ce dessin
et est-ce que si c'est un coup là
et du coup en fait aussi c'est peut-être
mieux de prendre de la taupe ah mais
c'est ça un peu quand même
si c'est un vrai coup
j'ai quand même la structure qui revient
à peu près
[Musique]
du coup donc on va
gagner on va dire le coup de 15 mois
[Musique]
peut-être du coup voilà mais
parce que tous les ans je peux pas le
faire à cause
plus sympa à jouer et sur ça du coup
regarder ce soir ou demain si on a dit
de la merde du tout ce qu'il a fait tu
auras D1 fais voir
et la fête foraine directement ici
et son idée c'est que
quel est ton point de 5 et 6
des trous recette pour descendre B7 un
peu toutes les pièces
si je fais que
[Musique]
mais du coup
tu peux pas vraiment
il est revenu
j'ai
mis ce clic c'est parce que je voulais
faire
mais j'ai vu mais je vais prendre un A8
faut des 6 qui est
comment tu m'aurais fait pousser cinq et
c'est cette recette
il faut il faut y croire après
du coup il commence à être
tu vas rentrer là
qui peut prendre des 5 c'est incroyable
après j'ai le droit de faire tu auras
des 8
et là et maintenant peut-être qu'il veut
aussi ici
merci pour le seul
[Musique]
j'ai raté
c'est simple pour tout le monde les
échecs même deux ans par jour
c'est pas la même c'est Pierre
[Musique]
parce que là ce retour là j'ai cavalier
5 ou est-ce que je fais contre contre
ok ok bon juste en fait ici si je prends
il va y avoir un couloir j'ai sur ton
ici on va contre-courage mais
apparemment j'ai cavale le 3 qui gagne
non
et cavalua ça a l'air ça a l'air OK
du coup du coup E6 part sur
[Musique]
et du coup du coup tourner
je bouffe et c'est 6 c'est la même
ça va pas ouais ça ça me plaît pas trop
regarde mais le pion va être faible même
cahier des quatre maintenant je peux
jouer ça va ça me plaît pas KFC donc tu
auras des un plutôt bien joué
ça me paraît complètement absurde
après il faut avoir envie
qui ressort pas
bon pratique ça n'a pas le choix tu vas
le faire mais bon tu vois ici les Blancs
n'ont pas forcés de manger des cinq ans
je sais pas bonne question mais
aussi pourquoi je suis pas bien
[Musique]
c'est pas si simple
c'est peut-être bien joué
la conception elle me fait un peu peur
tu vois je trouve plus que c'est un peu
bizarre mais
on prend un cahier
la caméra on voit que on peut les faire
[Musique]
rapidement si vous voulez
qui va défendre ça en chaussettes c'est
lui
c'est très fort
ok ok donc ça c'est fait
merci pour merci pour tous ces sœurs
on peut faire un petit tour
[Musique]
c'est parti c'est ça qu'on comprend lui
on a tout dit depuis le début
[Musique]
donc là un peu mieux pour les blancs un
petit tour d'horizon rapporte saut la
partie on s'en fout complet
ça marche pas bien
est-ce que je peux jouer
vas-y
parce que du coup j'ai
trompé
c'est parti
[Musique]
bon après il va
gagner des trois je sais pas
d'ailleurs peut-être pas tomber ça
mais quoi d'autre
même si tu perds un pion tu auras des
belles pièces
donc en plus si on fait ça plus tard
après on pourra mettre ici
[Musique]
donc c'est logique on s'enlève vis-à-vis
je pense que le plus dur est passé pour
un gars ici pas très impressionnant dans
l'ouverture encore une fois non non il a
été plutôt
donc on a le temps
il veut prendre
le gain presque avec les noix mais bon
tu peux te retrouver du coup avec un
plan de
il y a eu un coup de pluie
il y a eu
[Musique]
donc vraiment là il confirme un petit
peu le fait que son
navire
H3 ça a l'air de façon
mais il a fait une super idée dans
l'ouverture c'est dommage que
j'ai 4 assez étonnant quand même
pas prendre le 5 c'était peut-être le
truc clé
Maxence c'est vrai
je vais aller voir
[Musique]
OK
je m'attends à nul
toujours
et là tu me prends E7 tu vas tourner
cette aussi
c'est beaucoup moins fort que tout à
l'heure oui il y a plus l'idée de cette
caille D4 ici
pas non plus vraiment rêver d'être
beaucoup mieux avec les Noirs je me
souviens pas enflammé
ok ça va faire nul
tu peux être fier de jouer
[Musique]
encore une fois je
n'empêche tout le coup en fait
est-ce qu'il a pas eu peur dans le
cahier des 5 non
voir si je joue cavalier là là
[Musique]
du coup pour les caméras il me reste que
trois caméras de visibles
[Musique]
j'en ai une ou sur Prague et une sur ce
rapport tout ce que j'ai
ok
quand même
il peut pas vraiment être mieux
maintenant non non
mais
tourbillon je bouffe bouffe
et ton bain t'adore ces deux je peux pas
faire mal
après j'aurais ma fille donc les postes
ça sera mort ok ça marche pas de souci
à tout de suite
je vais partir sur
la vie de la salle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Mathieu
et on a joué
une connerie
non mais Abdou il est même s'il a un
poil moins bien il défend hyper bien
alors je voulais qu'on regarde la partie
de carwana parce qu'il a joué un coup
qui nous a surpris qui est pas bon
qu'on avait proposé donc nous on a dit
on fait H3 et on attaque
dans le désert
après avoir retourné
page de B5 le pion est tombé
quand on appelle ça il a incité à jeb5
comme il a bougé là
après niveau mental pas trop ton idée
mais des fois ça peut marcher
merci Monsieur Conan
sur ma vidéo de ce matin je vais essayer
d'en faire tous les jours mais là genre
là la ronde de demain si je fais la
vidéo c'est je la fais tout seul
[Musique]
c'est un peu
il est mieux
c'est vrai que on est un peu sur notre
fin parce que là le petit je crois nous
paraissait quand même très fort
on avait on avait vu des lignes comme ça
avec du Roy F2 tour-acha même pensé
aussi à le G3 d'abord
et
c'est sûr qu'on a une position hyper
agréable
mais du coup
c'est plus c'est peut-être le
professionnel j'en sais rien
une de mes meilleurs amis il avait une
expression il disait c'est le coup
d'iscar c'est la personne la connaît
j'ai vérifié personne autre sur Terre à
17 expression l'idée c'est le coup de
l'accordéon un coup à gauche un quadro
c'était une personne assez agile qui est
malheureusement décédée
vous connaissez pas l'expression non
tu connais non c'était tabaroni
peut-être
en couleur on va dire
pour moi
donc ouais il fait un cours d'ams2 à 4
c'est hyper bizarre
le principe de l'accordéon
mais du coup là concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'ils font les noirs
[Musique]
pour ouvrir le renard
ok bon
[Musique]
idée de foudre
je préfère manger la qualité que ouais
mais par exemple ça par exemple ça
est-ce que c'est clair que ça
non mais stratégiquement quand tu fais
que G6 je pense que tu as un problème
non je peux pas prendre en G6 tourner
la finale en ligne non
ok
il veut te donner la qualité
je peux pas défendre mes pions
des trois en plus il va être un prix 3
fois donc j'ai pas le temps de venir
défendre et faire [ __ ]
ça m'a l'air un peu en plus je pense pas
que de toute façon
ça me saoule vas-y
tu vois enfin moi c'est clairement un
truc que je pourrais faire
au vu du tournoi mais mais lui je pense
qu'il est pas du tout comme ça là
tu peux jamais être mieux
ouais je sais pas moi j'espère en fait
ton final là où je peux bouffer ton
cavalier mais bon on lui va pas nous
laisser faire
maintenant tu veux jouer ksj6 prendre
deux roues
on fait un petit tour on a quoi Aniche
un
jour
sur le coup d'avant
pour découvrir
après menacerait
[Musique]
me débarrasser de ça et faire cavaler
aussi
malheureusement ça ça
va lui aussi
ça a pas l'air d'être génial pour
des schémas un peu du style pour deux
trois tours J3 qui ont l'air un peu
chiant aussi après la prise aussi ça
[Musique]
40 minutes ok bah ça va se décanter dans
l'heure là comme d'habitude
[Musique]
on nous dit on nous parle de la partie
de vermeerdam on n'a pas trop suivi mais
j'ai vu qu'elle avait une bonne position
encore avec les Noirs la sacrifie un
pion dans l'ouverture
alors karouana donc c'est l'avantage
on regarde jamais non ah oui c'est ça
[Musique]
si on veut manger arriver jusqu'à
la ligne c'est ça donc
là on va voir de quoi il mange
je pense quand même plus dans l'esprit
ça a déjà été
là on va avoir droit
mais encore
presque
changer en fait
ouais mais je vais me prendre ton fou je
vais essayer de jouer un torque
en une nul et clairement le résultat le
plus logique
pas très intéressant rapporte ça c'était
pas très intéressant aussi que ça a
bougé
alors
[Musique]
des outils
c'était la menace après qu'elle a plus
de cases
et du coup
[Musique]
j'arrive pour moi c'est hyper dur à
évaluer ses positions ouais bon soit on
arrive à récupérer le pion je suis pas
mal quoi
je le récupère pas et ça peut être
compliqué en fait
mais là c'est clair que les couloirs on
a assez simple là je me laisse cavalier
8 ans je crois
essayer
simple mais c'est un peu moins donc si
tu le regagnes normalement je devrais
pouvoir m'en sortir avec une mes parents
si je fais un coup comme torrent des
fois il peut avoir des idées sur B6 sera
pour moi
ton B4 qui peut être aussi encore une
idée tu vas peut-être un tour à essayer
d'abord pour fixer
et venir à toi à 4 cavaler B5 tour à 4
mais
[Musique]
et ça doit aller
ça doit aller pour le nom mais ils vont
devoir être précis peut-être pas
précis comme ça enfin si les noirs sont
pas précis ils peuvent perdre quoi et
pour ça je pense que le rapport est
juste pour le résultat ici
on l'a vu craquer
rapport moi la partie qui m'a fait le
plus triper
[Musique]
et du coup alors la partie qui nous
réussit le plus
la partie là
pourquoi pas qui est des 7 fous des deux
c'est logique
pour moi ça
a été pas contente là parce qu'il y a eu
un truc
il a raté un coup
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est un coup
ça a l'air d'être il y a pas que vous
prend
ça
a l'air fort
[Musique]
c'est bizarre tu penses qu'il a vraiment
raté je vais vérifier ben
c'est pas la partie
qu'on regarde
[Musique]
la F4 il y avait dame F6
parce que cavalier H5 kg
[Musique]
à la place de foot
après en pratique ça a l'air quand même
pas facile pour les Noirs toujours
tu prends le blanc ici
[Musique]
pas fini du coup Roger
donc ça peut faire nul s'il veut
aller voir ce qu'il nous fait le petit
goûter
mais là j'ai peur qu'il faut qu'ils
jugent reprend J6 seul coup c'est
exactement ce qu'on a dit
[Musique]
et j'ai 6 prises mais maintenant il
reprend et ça a été joué pour apprendre
et là faut juger cette position
c'est pas si simple
est-ce que je peux jouer un petit G4
F6
beaucoup d'avant au lieu de prendre G6
qui prend le 5 et tu revenais
la structure mais bon
je te pose je sais pas il pense
parce qu'en fait sinon il peut jouer
avec eux
je sais pas
maintenant le prince c'est que tu as
comme talqué E3 pour empêcher au F5 tu
peux plus monter ton roi c'est pour ça
que tu es pas mieux en fait
comme ça
finalement on avait dit qu'il allait
qu'il était mieux mais on pensait pas
qu'il allait arriver
le coup
ok pour être plus fort que le cavalier
ça c'est clair après de la donner
avantage net on aurait changé les dames
avec les noirs
[Musique]
il faut évaluer ça en fait les cavaliers
dans les finales ils ont un défaut
contre les fous c'est qu'ils ont des
petites jambes
[Musique]
du coup bah du coup c'est à cause de ça
que c'est avantage les les cavalier
quand les pions sont du même côté des
trois là il est en mode on m'étonne
c'est chiant après la finale fou contre
cavalier
normalement
oui je pense tu ramènes le roi et
tu connais la règle des trois colonnes
tout ils ont
c'est qui
tu as de bonnes chances de gain
pourquoi parce qu'il y a trois colonnes
en fait c'est que
quand tu as deux colonnes le cavalier
peut passer plus facilement d'une aile à
l'autre et tu as des cases fortes au
centre de la casse des quatre
ouais
ça logique en fait
après là dans le cas présent tu peux
peut-être pas l'avoir
parce que je vais jouer le tour
je vais pas échanger la torche des deux
sans doute
mais d'ailleurs
en fait moi du coup je peux jouer ça ça
et mon idée de tout à l'heure ça ça quoi
F6 comment est-ce que tu es vraiment
dans les temps pour aller fin fois
mais ça ça pour moi c'est l'enfer
peut-être encore
et oui mais là il est clairement pas
bien là
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer du blanc
[Musique]
ok il peut la perdre
je pensais un coup de débile du style
dame C1 pour te dire
mais bon
c'est un peu plus bouger d'ailleurs
on voulait les voir à ce niveau-là tu
vois qu'ils ont encore du chemin ouais
c'est clair
genre jamais à rognon aurait perdu enfin
aurait menacé de perdre cette position
agréablement je pense
oui oui ils arrivent en fait quand on va
être le danger ils arrivent à faire du
direct quoi
il risque de s'offrir un peu cette
partie
ça peut aller est-ce qu'il y a eu des
coups
il est perdu donc tant qu'à faire on va
essayer de casser un peu la structure
comprends ok bon moi j'ai
[Rires]
pour finalement
c'est une grosse c'est une faute chez
moi de quoi pardon et je sais pas c'est
moi il y a marqué qu'il a joué H4
vérifier
mais à jour
[Musique]
à ce niveau là c'est pas c'est chaud
quoi
en fait
mais je reviens en pierre
non peut-être qu'il veut fouder ça qui
est ramener les tours sur la colonne
chaud
je vais regarder parce que ça change
tout le temps mais
j'écoute trois non j'ai une partie j'ai
non je sais pas
j'ai chaud j'ai Prague et j'ai une qui
sert à rien j'aimerais bien voir la tête
de Carole
[Musique]
c'est choquant parce que c'est vrai la
probabilité que donner le pion ça soit
marche et qu'elle faible ça reste un
pion mais la partie est très bizarre
comment ils ont changé les fous
par contre bon il va gagner je pense
assez facile Google si on pense à faire
annuler il a il a joué il a joué
je voulais faire ton idée
c'est pas mal mais bon il va parfois
c'est le jour il fait 6
est-ce que je peux pas jouer un petit B3
pour venir en BK
mais maintenant
pour finir
il y a vraiment une
ça fait nul
après l'ordi mettez 0 0 après KF3
OK
donc à rognon il a poussette
mais il faut changer
elle est nulle mais il faut la jouer
sinon tour des deux tu peux peut-être
aller ailleurs
mais où c'est ça
c'est vraiment le coup
qui m'embête
à moins qu'il a envie de faire regarde
B3 donc
[Applaudissements]
ça ça
[Musique]
c'est quand même le coup qui fait chier
quoi
[Musique]
je suis vraiment vraiment bloqué
de Prague je viens de voir
Prague un pour Robinson
bon tu peux pas prendre un H2 enfermer
la dame
en fait les Noirs ont réussi à trouver
du jeu quand même un peu
ça doit être moins bien mais ils ont
trouvé déjà par contre les deux regarde
25 minutes pour 20 coups
ça peut partir en cacahuète
ça peut être chaud encore
j'ai un qui peut arriver plus tard
[Musique]
en F1 F2
les noirs peuvent jouer Dame des quatre
j'y crois pas du tout prise il y a du
Cap
comment ça marche
tu dois prendre de la
tour
ça y ressemble mais on dirait qu'il y a
pas de refus non parce que j'ai surtout
pas envie de manger juste pour expliquer
au chat ça serait une horreur pour les
pour les blancs en pratique parce que
bon après pour voir si vraiment ça gagne
direct voilà
un truc qui peut être pas mal voir ça ça
avec des problèmes de partout soit les
Noirs s'installe avec cavalence à 5 sous
les trois ça peut très vite venir
l'horreur quoi donc concrètement en fait
il faut voir qu'elle va être 5 ça va pas
mal qu'avec le cadre pas mal que solide
bloque la colonne
mais
ayez car wanna il a joué qui apprend G4
ça a été joué j'ai l'impression qu'il a
fait exprès l'autre un grand malade
tempo
des trois tours
proche de gagnant le roi est trop faible
fouet 5 et monstrueux
tu as vraiment besoin de faire ça c'est
cool la position elle écrasante après
matérialiste
tu as pas envie je sais pas c'est
d'aller manger des pions normalement
c'est dangereux
peut-être que c'est débile
non mais il écoute
actuellement c'est pas mal ce qu'il a
fait je crois vraiment qu'il a fait
exprès
un peu où tu peux avoir du jeu
pour prendre en plein matériel
des pions pour la qualité
ça veut dire qu'on est devant même et le
roi est toujours faible elle aurait
faible
j'ai plein d'idées
F5 est très faible
faut faire gaffe ce que je peux prendre
en F5 et reprendre du pion F genre de la
dame plutôt
ça marche peut-être comme ça comme ça
mais en fait juste à la fin j'ai eu peur
que tu me reprends un 5 sur ce que tu as
dit mais peut-être ça marche pas
faut prendre puis on prend pour prendre
peut-être qu'il y a kavihashis qui gagne
3 échec à la fin donc tu as raison ça
marche
si tu en prends un 5 et H6
et du coup je fais échec le roi de
rester au contact de la tour sinon il
perd la tour et après moi j'ai 7 et bien
[Musique]
contrôle la case c'est parfait
ça m'arrange même et la joie
donc il faut qu'il fasse gaffe 19
minutes pour deux secondes
à la caméra
[Musique]
j'ai malheureusement tiens j'ai sauté
j'ai chaud et j'y rapporte quasiment
rien vu mais je vais pas te mentir je
comprenais rien la position
[Musique]
et bon F4 par une pièce un coup tour B4
B5 était enfermé
j'aurais peur avec les blancs en fait
c'est un truc tu fais une erreur de
calcul tu peux te retrouver à faire tes
pions
[Musique]
complètement
je trouve que c'est trop trop comique
ok donc rapporte un peu en en jeu bon on
n'est pas sûr mais
en tout cas
j'ai vu sur la caméra
et du coup on pensait à Robin mais du
coup B4 après avoir
en fait l'idée
ça se calcule mais quatre échecs
c'est chiant à calculer son nom
[Musique]
si tu peux pas jouer dans ma tête
oui il a peut-être un truc là mais je
pense je l'ai pas ouais
mais c'est ça je voulais faire
[Musique]
j'ai pas F4
qui me gêne mais
parce que
j'ai rien là-haut il y a toujours une
camels qui vont se défendre entre eux
[Musique]
est-ce que tu avais joué
en français
mais ça c'est gagnant il faut juste
réfléchir à pénible
ça doit être le coup
sinon tu joues dans 8
comme
[Musique]
des cartes tout le temps
fermer la
[Musique]
envisageable
on est vraiment
ouais ouais tu sens mais après mon
Prague il calcule mieux que nous hein je
pense que
tu vas trouver quelque chose
je me souviens quand j'étais quand on a
fait le stage en Inde avec un échec il y
a
il y a maintenant cinq six ans quoi et
ben il avait quoi il avait il avait 14
ans 15 ans 14 ans il avait je pense 13
14 ans
il avait 2480 il était maître
et il faisait tous les cours qu'il
faisait même les tactiques et tout
aveugle
une machine tu vois genre les études que
moi je passais une demi-heure bah lui il
faisait à l'aveugle il était beaucoup
plus rapide que moi il avait 13 ans quoi
notre idée ouais mais là ça là ça va
tomber les pieds
faibles
au pire des cas tu sais peut-être
il nous reste quoi en fait on a eu deux
matchs nuls déjà entre parrain et Aniche
ouais et on a d'autres parties qui vont
sûrement stimuler par un on a goût cash
et abdos qui font pas grand chose
il a réussi à virer la tour tu vois
regarde il a réussi au final
il peut y avoir un
petit léger
[Musique]
tu es trop une idée
après ce que les noirs peuvent gagner ça
franchement je pense pas tu peux pas
remplacer ton roi
donc nul c'est normal
pour bloquer en fait si tu peux faire G4
et un coup les blancs serait largement
mieux quoi
et malheureusement tu peux pas tout
faire quoi tu gagnes après
[Musique]
un peu mais là je peux même pas tourner
en fait
on comprend rien qui est mort et en
danger contre Prague et caroann avant
forest c'était le plus important
qui
risque de de se terminer
assez rapidement et en quoi je peux pas
manger en C4
[Musique]
gros craquage de ventes forest non
mauvaise partie
je pense le coup critique
[Musique]
la position en fait elle donnait c'est
intéressant s'il a fait dans l'ouverture
mais au final un sur long terme on
l'avait dit que la case noire à la case
de 5 c'était toujours un problème donc
sixième
et au final
[Musique]
juste un très bon joueur d'échec place
bien ses pièces
et la partie de caravane franchement
elle est le bon plan
donc il nous reste quoi d'intéressant le
plus intéressant c'est peut-être qu'on a
en vidéo c'est praguemer
je pense qu'on va rester là-dessus parce
que là dès que ça bouge on peut aller
voir pour l'instant à l'instant un peu
de partout on me dit plusieurs fois dans
quelle partie déjà
effectivement ouais en fait il faut
toujours que je le
ce qu'on a dit
et ça j'ai dit que j'y croyais pas à
cause de D6 à 5 ans prises
[Musique]
sur chaque position en fait ah oui
d'accord
puis on prend des 6
plutôt du coup donc il a fait ça mais là
ça s'appelle le marché du tout non prise
au 5 prisonnier
je prends
je prends un 5 en fait juste à la fin il
va pas manquer
tu as l'air complètement fini
[Musique]
ça serait bête
tu laisses tomber deux mais tu laisses
qui est pour l'instant et surtout pas
dans quel sens mais
qu'est-ce qu'il réfléchit à quoi il y a
un autre coup enfin
[Musique]
c'est ce que j'aurais joué aussi ok
c'est 5
tu as même pas qui est B3
[Musique]
il faut bien vérifier que
je vais activer tout seul c'est pas fini
Google
ok la jauge
la jauge dit qu'il y a un coup qui
défend
UE
mais est-ce que tu dois échanger les
tours
vas-y tu peux le mettre Thor C8 qui est
de français 4 est-ce que tu dois
échanger
c'est foot
ça a l'air 2 en fait tu as pas de pion
fuck encore manger et tu as du mal à
tout peut-être qu'il faut garder il faut
trouver une colonne
il n'y a pas de réponse évidente
et du coup tu me laisses
assez une meilleure version pour moi
peut-être
est-ce qu'on peut montrer pour ces deux
qu'elle a l'air fort en fait ça perd les
cahiers
donc du coup qu'est-ce qui doit faire
sur ton regard
droite
[Musique]
et je veux jouer
sur le fil c'est proche de perdant mais
pour l'instant on va
cailler des quatre ouais c'était pas
bête mais après tu peux aussi jouer
[Musique]
pas encore fini ok
en carwana comment il a donné la qualité
finalement l'autre enfin l'autre est-ce
qu'il a prise
donc il a bien joué autour des trois tu
reprends
et 4 le cavalier il est il est c'est la
meilleure pièce des blancs pas même pas
sûr
je voudrais bien souvent s'il est comme
ça
c'est incroyable dessin que c'est
terminé en fait tient tout le foot tient
tout
tu peux aussi menacer juste de prendre
un F5 des fois
pour avoir un pion encore en fait les
Noirs encore une fois ils ont pas ils
ont pas de plan quoi c'est horrible
H3 je te fais G3 je ferme la baraque
donc il a tenté quelque chose direct OK
ouais il a un petit peu mieux voir un
peu F2
mais comment tu fais ici du coup
tu as pas de Tours
des deux si il y a besoin
vous ferez 4 et si tu prends des uns et
prends
etc
comment tu défends à 4 j'ai pas compris
tu vois ce que je veux dire
mais juste
ça ne saute pas aux yeux
bonjour Olito mais oui le chat est un
peu mou là tout à l'heure
au lieu de roi F7 à 5 à 4 x 6 je sais
pas de quoi tu parles
au lieu de
prend il faut F6 en prison
mais
c'est un peu sur un film mais ça m'a
l'air
et tu ferais mieux tu as plus qu'à aller
ok j'ai 4
et 3
je vais avoir
je m'en fous pas de tout garder
malheureusement
ok bon il y a une petite pression petite
pression blanche éventuellement si
j'arrive à Montréal
c'est pas mieux en fait c'est plutôt il
y a pas de pression non est-ce qu'on
peut aller voir la partie qui nous
intéresse pas rapports
et puis ça va faire un nul je pense
ça va jouer encore un petit peu
j'ai pas le niveau pour te dire
directement les Noirs
[Musique]
comment tu fais
si je mets mon rond E3 F4 et je mets mon
rond à 4 tu vas devoir jouer F6 c'est ça
et si tu fais si je reviens à chauffage
jamais en fait
oui oui c'est ça les noirs doivent
donner un pion mais du coup ils sont pas
mieux c'est à la base on pensait que les
Noirs pouvaient être mieux
il y a eu des coups dans la partie de
Prague parce que je l'ai sur l'autre
ordi
et vivement il a pas joué le mieux
[Musique]
je pense être au moins mais ils disent
aussi quel est ces trois ou X5 aucun des
deux il a joué on le voit donc là il
veut jouer kyd4 il veut que des 4 un
coup fout prend à 5
mais bon
tu peux pas
bouger trop loin je peux pas
[Musique]
être joué et peut-être pas faut prendre
des seins
un gros détour
ou alors tu ramènes ton roi pour faire
Kayser 5 mais il manque un temps non
[Musique]
pour moi c'est le plus logique mais à
mon avis
en tout cas
franchement
ouais ouais
en fait
dans la partie de dérivée ici et un truc
à voir
que on nous a dit dans le chat
déjà prise ouais c'est la partie
[Musique]
peut-être
tu as des chances de gain
d'avoir provoqué B3 à 4 pour que le roi
rentre je m'en intuition me dit que
c'est nul mais c'est pas pour moi pas
évident non
ok c'est forcément 2
mais bon
mais ça va
on va de 3
tu peux perdre non
il faut compter même cavalier à être une
menace aussi
je vois à droite
ok donc
il y a pas de mauvais coup normalement
manger je ne l'ai pas considéré
5 après
pour changer les pièces
[Musique]
un prix c'est pas bête
j'aime bien la team poussée mais
peut-être que là c'est bête
la tombée un peu bête mais
[Musique]
t'as vu la jauge
aussi enfin j'aime bien manger en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas mal aussi
je pousse sans réfléchir le message
c'est des fois j'oublie qu'on peut
manger un pion en un couple
c'est pour les cases et pour tu vois ça
me donne des colonnes des âges pas que
par principe
[Musique]
donc il va la jouer c'est mieux pour les
blancs mais c'est peut-être là
maintenant j'en sais rien ouais
c'est probablement top
les ressources qu'ils ont à ce niveau là
parce que franchement
cette partie là ben moi je l'aurais pas
dû déjà dit quoi
et ils ont des ressources tu vois quand
il a enfin il est rentré dans cette dans
cette je pense que avec F4 D3 il avait
déjà vu toute la suite
ça va faire nul je crois que c'est pas
intéressant c'est ça
je pense que ça
quoi que ce n'est pas si
je pense qu'on va arriver là il se met
ici
non mais si je fais deux trois F4 quand
tu fais ça
pas obligé de manger si tu bouffes
malheureusement
je le ferai
il a pas joué ce qu'on a dit avec les
noirs et là je fous en E7 au lieu de fou
en B2
[Musique]
on n'a pas on n'a pas les coups on a une
jauge
à contente ils ont joué ils ont joué
pour expliquer je fais Rebecca à 5 à 4 à
3 à 2 et je t'abandonne donc tu dois
jouer à C4 pour empêcher le roi de
sortir de la colonne A pour obstruer
l'option
et tu as le contre jeu avec le Pione
ouais juste attends
un coup
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
c'est obligé
tu rois des trois épis
la question c'est est-ce que je pense
que c'est important pour le contre-jour
parce que au final
ça va ça sent le long terme je vais je
vais me repositionner et puis je vais
danser mon pion ça va être deux jours
enfin
non croisé 4 faut gs5
ça commence à être à sentir mauvais
il va y avoir voilà donc tu as besoin de
faire un 5
je pousse et 5
il faut que je pousse c'est pas le soir
tu peux jouer non
tu me donnes ton pion je te demande
après c'est peut-être encore nul ok ça
doit tenir Rebecca
pourquoi tu fais que des deux
c'est fini fin de la 3 ici
un paroi bien si tu fais à trois
peut pas manger parce qu'il y a là en
fait
il y a le petit
ok ça a l'air nul mais car il F1 ça peut
faire peur
mais au final ça peut être une fausse
frayeur enfin ça peut vraiment être un
faux piège quoi
alors Prague qu'est-ce qui nous fait
calculer du B il y a une uleule entre
darcelles
vraiment vraiment
ça répète là ça commence à répéter
le mec il attend
il faisait rien oui
il faudrait pas prendre F4 non si je
mange je perds parce que bah ça et puis
je poussais mes pions tout simplement
d'ailleurs si tu as les blancs tu fais
pas comme ça d'ailleurs
[Musique]
tu peux pas créer de pion passé avec ce
54 alléluia
que j'ai aussi des plans qui avancent
donc non ça va répéter juste en fait tu
vas essayer 4 et que il va voir ça
marche pas
donc ça ça va être une partie nulle je
pense qu'il y a pas trop trop à s'en
faire il y a eu Robert 5 F4 d'ailleurs
ça va se serrer la pâte
est-ce que ça perd pour la blague la
chose j'avais pas l'air de dire que ça
partait encore
c6f5 et je me fais un pion ici quand
même manger cinq
non je prends je fais ça ah oui en fait
j'ai cette possibilité là qui est un peu
longue mais je suis sain avec le poids
qui mange F7 et le plomb qui avance et
j'ai aussi mangé d'art faire G6 et une
fois que le pion est fait parti j'ai
mangé le 6 et je pousse depuis longtemps
ok donc il nous reste 49 peut-être le
plus intéressant du coup
est-ce qu'il y a eu des coups il a mangé
il aurait pu manger
et prenez 5 à la fin il perdait super
bien
et qui fait tout ça pour empêcher en
fait les échanges quoi tu vois donc il
joue l'activité au max
mais pour B7 dans le 6
tu peux me prendre des enfants
[Musique]
de mes pièces et puis voir ce qui se
passe
j'avais pris en C5 pour faire Dame des 5
ou cavalier des 5 quoi est-ce que tu
peux jouer ici
[Musique]
qui me demande dans le chat c'était une
partie à analyser une partie sympa je
pense que la partie de
celle-là
pour l'instant c'est parti pas terrible
mais c'est la meilleure non non en fait
le lien dans l'ouverture à l'intérieur
déjà et puis l'ouverture est
intéressante nouvelle idée puis très mal
joué stratégiquement après tu as aussi
celle de Prague qui est intéressant
niveau conception au niveau ça va finir
c'est la vidéo elle va dire 8 heures ils
ont pas encore fini ils en ont encore
pour un moment celle-là c'est bon
regarde les parties non mais celle-là
elle est intéressante
[Musique]
20 minutes
après
la partie pragamer elle est intéressante
mais il y a
y avait deux trois trucs stratégiques à
dire qui est mère a bien entendu quand
il était mal non je pense ça là c'est la
meilleure mais il faudrait qu'il gagne
quand même avec les
et du coup t'as pas compris que je te
proposais C6 pour les noirs pour les
blancs
[Musique]
à la base c'est quand même que que
le français 6
non c'est vrai que le jour du tournoi le
moins bien dans le sens où pour
l'instant il y a eu deux parties qui
étaient superbes les deux que j'ai
commenté l'assemblée
[Musique]
rien du tout OK
la finale Prague tu peux montrer et pour
cette certitude
c'est assez professionnel
[Musique]
on peut la regarder ici ils ont joué ce
qu'on a dit ou pas
il a peur de roi C4 faut que je sens une
cavaliers il peut de choc
pardon stratégiquement je fais roi BK
[Musique]
si je le vois en fait faut G5 je me dis
merde
ça va quoi
[Musique]
il a gardé son pion l'autre l'a pris et
du coup
tu vas où avec ton cheval
Ier vous savez qu'on a reposer si on
mange ouais c'est pas très compliqué
[Musique]
d'aller chercher un petit thé là c'est
pas fini la finale
c'est arrivé à Sami je contre Salgado
un championnat en Espagne et Sami avait
une position
égale façon finale il allait faire nulle
quoi et il se lève au 40e is Lay va
prendre bateau
et pas entière
enfin derrière le temps 40e quoi et
maintenant c'est terminé
à part
j'ai perdu une partie en 7 heures en
Allemagne
j'en pouvais plus physiquement
parce que l'avantage c'est de pouvoir
changer les cavaliers en fait
l'arbitre et maman il m'a dit
vous pouvez renoter votre partie il y a
130 coups j'arrive pas à vous
j'ai dit non
pendant la partie un moment il ferme il
ouvre la fenêtre il faisait froid je dis
tu pouvais la fermer il m'a dit non j'ai
m'énerver et après je dis si tu veux je
te l'envoie demain par mail la partie
toi
je suis parti
[Musique]
et je ferai Dame des cinq quand même non
parce que si tu joues dans le 6 je sais
si
tu peux pas faire ça je pense c'est trop
chaud
je vais même cavaler prendre 5 jolies
[Musique]
il reste 40 secondes
s'il lui reste à l'ouest peu de temps
mais j'ai pas les caméras
malheureusement j'ai que la caméra sur
Prague quoi il y a aucune caméra qui
marche tout seul
quand il est mal au temps j'ai trois
caméras et trois caméras sont sur
prattes quand même c'est incroyable
F8 tu fais fout des 6 c'est ça
je pense j'aime bien c'est très bien
je l'ai pas vu moi je t'avais dit moi
j'avais vu tous les quatre juste je
voulais défendre mon pion mais en fait
c'est vrai que des six elle a encore
plus fort et épreuve
[Musique]
c'est la partie ça va être il nous reste
30 secondes pour mettre deux coups
et on peut sûrement voir un abandon de
votre reste après les 40e
parce qu'avec 50 minutes
pour répondre
il y a pas de coups pour moi
il y a 30 secondes par contre non plus
30 secondes
à jouer
c'est chiant
et ok dernier piège toi tu tentes
[Rires]
[Musique]
il a défendu avec le camion A6 faire
blocus casse blanche direct ok très
cohérent d'ailleurs moi j'ai proposé
qu'il y a aussi pour viser la
les couleurs opposées
voilà
s'échangent
de plus mais ça a pas l'air de
6 ans ça peut être gagnant déjà et même
ça c'est pas sûr
qu'il y aura contre jeu avec le pion F
et cetera
plus de 30 secondes à la pendule
et
pour juste un coup donc
[Musique]
on me demande mes prochaines séances je
donne une simultanée et en région
parisienne ce week-end
non je vais jouer le tournoi de
Reykjavik Open en avril enfin mars
quand on est en vacances que j'adore
j'aime bien
je vais aller mais
j'ai eu très très bons échos je sais que
tu vas souvent avec même Amazon
on gagne jamais un prix une fois Libye a
gagné un prix
ils ont changé le règlement à cause de
lui
en fait il a pris deux balles
il a eu droit maintenant le premier
départage et le nombre de parties jouets
bon bon bon
et si il fait un autre coup tu reviens à
ans
oui
c'est simple en fait parce que imaginons
qu'il y avait des trois
je sais pas mais en fait moi je crois
que tu manges c'est la question
parce que moi du roi ok toi aussi
ça me va
ma dernière partie avec non non j'ai
joué Google cette année j'ai fini la
République et je suis rouge là il y a 2
ans d'ailleurs non la dernière partie je
veux contre ça Jeff
je faisais un super tournoi je perds un
coup contre Prague ça m'a mis dedans
et après j'ai mal fini le tournoi de nul
lui ok il va prendre son temps car on a
eu du coup il y a eu des coups il a
passé le contrôle OK
j'ai perdu dans la théorie j'ai confondu
de ligne
donc
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on a dit
il a raison d'ailleurs
un truc marcher un peu
quoi Prague oui il reste Prague
apparemment ça va être la nulle et le
cas
[Musique]
on se prend là je prends là mais
de très bonne chance
[Musique]
moi je peux jouer la même ou alors G6 ah
j'ai 6 qui avait lieu trois et mon four
revient pas peut-être c'est ça
non mais moi je suis pas je m'en fous de
ce
je sais pas en fait il a pas joué ça il
a joué système pour
tout de suite je pense
ah mais oui non mais il reste 40
secondes c'est pour ça qu'il ajoute un
pot il y a du sens ouais il reste 40
secondes et maintenant que
les Blancs ont des petites chances
maintenant pratique encore
c'est pour ça que je trouvais ça assez
con
[Musique]
moi aussi
c'est pas juste pourquoi pas c'est
comment il parle
il va
il faut qu'il soit quel pion il veut
défendre avec son fou quoi
c'est la partie
on peut que de quoi
j'ai 4g5 non mais j'ai 4 qui avait ici
je peux vous mettre la vue si vous
voulez que les caméras qui sont grandes
avec les Blancs et du coup
sont à quel coût qui regarde sa feuille
dans les tournois quand il y a un écran
avec ta partie retransmise au dessus
comme ça je regardais les coups
[Musique]
on a plus le temps du coup
moi il en reste là il est tombé en fait
c'est à dire le temps
qu'il a eu son dernier coup avec trois
secondes à la pendule ils ont en
rajoutant de 50 minutes
pourquoi j'ai pas je vendeur j'ai été
malade avant d'y aller j'ai pas envie
après j'étais déjà malade et en fait
tournoi de ronde par jour quand tu es
malade avant d'arriver tu sens que la
semaine va
me reposer ok donc quelle est la 5
il peut faire quel B6 d'ailleurs
ça se joue un temps pour prévu j'ai
l'impression que ça fait nul le nom qui
est B6 3D 8
poubelle 2
on perds
pref 6
et ça a l'air de tenir
je peux le montrer aux gens
[Musique]
je peux pas pousser parce que je vais
tout prendre
et on prochain
après qui est prend un 5 KLF 6 donc
l'idée
[Musique]
tu fais comment
à la fin non mes parents
[Musique]
en fait
grosse défense de Kemer il a l'air
dégoûté ouais un peu voilà il calcule là
c'est la machine là il sait déjà si
c'est nul ou pas
[Musique]
que j'étais en train de dire et après on
a changé d'avis
[Musique]
sur un attends il nous reste un rognan
il reste à voir il a trouvé on peut
aller voir
la quête
un coup en disant ouais c'est 4 il faut
pas avoir peur de fouger 5 je vais
remettre la caméra
mais c'est pas encore nul d'ailleurs il
peut la donc il a fait le fameux roi C4
bon coup pour empêcher le roi et là il a
fait roi à 5 donc E4 3B 6
les noirs sont mieux
il a bien joué un
parce que à partir de l'autre côté on a
vu que tu pouvais perdre ça marche la
courbe qui
non mais du coup j'ai toujours ce petit
fouet
mal placé mais R3
ça doit être nul mais moi j'aurais peur
avec les Blancs
il a fini
c'est ce qu'on a dit d'ailleurs la ligne
OK
grosse partie de
assez bizarre ouais il y a eu des
réactions des coups un peu bizarres de
la part de la part de
vent de Forest mais
je vais demander avec Kevin s'il veut
qu'on fasse une vidéo ou pas je fasse
alors du coup il nous reste ces deux
nulles de position
au final des plaisantes quand on est nul
et les deux Indiens
donc là
il va falloir qu'il démontre quelque
chose
qui est en train de mener
un petit peu la baguette
qui est ici
ou roi des 8 ou roi C8 d'ailleurs
c'est quand même assez
ouais voilà du coup
[Musique]
pratique après ça nul
enfin peut-être
[Musique]
ça marche pas ouais ça marche pas du
tout
là c'est désagréable c'est peut-être ça
c'est peut-être pas dans le 17
et comment je bouge avec les Noirs comme
mon plan
ça s'approcher
je pense c'est ça qu'il faut éviter
c'est un temps prêt sinon
et là faut trouver le plus secure
peut-être vous des cinq
tu mets le point aussi c'est ça
après parce que si je fais roi des 7 je
me reprends le cavalier
F6 D7 que je voulais pas donc faut des 5
vas-y admettons
ouais ouais
mais il peut encore se tromper
mais du coup en fait limite la plus
intéressante c'est l'autre maintenant à
rognan
je trouve qu'il y a plein de pièges de
partout
peut-être que roi C8 c'est en pratique
c'est plus simple pour lui du coup
peut-être qu'on fait dans l'autre sens
qu'elle prend achète je fais genre que
ici ce truc en fait je joue pas du tout
pour manger le pion je joue pour ce que
tu as dit qu'il y ait des 8 et attends
que ce pion est là tes pièces sont là un
peu passives donc autant que ce pion en
live va jouer
ok ils ont joué ce qu'on a dit
ok G4 pour avoir du sens un peu plus
bizarre
mais les noirs qui ont mis la pression
un peu dans cette partie quand même
désolé je regarde le tournoi des trucs
avec les noirs
donc nul
il est bon c'est ça
il y avait une partie il y avait une
partie célèbre
qu'ils avaient joué
il y a eu un dame prend B6 avec blanc
comme ça je sais plus c'est bien
car scène s'est fait franchement qui
streamait
sur Youtube ou quoi tu peux trouver car
ça me saoule et qui a perdu sa deuxième
partie de suite
le Grand Maître
je le connais bien parce que
on a le même âge et on sait jouer genre
plusieurs fois le championnat jaune
et après
la vidéo là
il s'est fait franchement la partie elle
est belle
qui a fait le job
ah il a joué
la partie donc youpi contre Carlsen et
non c'est une immortel ouais tu vois
c'est le sur Internet pendant un string
c'est pas le truc tu vois
c'est pas le truc très
important mais bon c'est parti
alors du coup cavaniage de ça a été joué
on n'a pas eu H5 jouer noir
H5 donc
est-ce que tu veux non
et après avoir un petit peu si on peut
ramener la cabane
il est juste revenu en 5 B6 parce que
quand c'est fan descendait avec le roi
il perdait avec les Noirs
mais ça doit tenir
mais ouais ouais
c'est parti ils l'ont pas joué on se
retrouve je le vois la caméra
je vais vous mettre l'autre l'autre vue
là parce que là du coup
je vous laisse celle là
ça joue pas au moins vous voyez
ce qui se passe alors qu'on voit
Hannibal contre don chenco derrière qui
serre la main c'est la tournoi
Challenger
on vous laisse comme ça de toute façon
on est parti à l'avance pas et il se
passe pas grand chose et dès que ça
avance et ben de toute façon on vous
dira
on va les deux en même temps donc là
donc pour 7 et puis
et puis ça a l'air d'être cavalier des
cartes par exemple pas trop trop de
moyens de plus en fait c'est le seul
truc où oui
peut être dérangeant puis on peut
acheter
c'est vraiment
tu vois si jamais bon finalement il y
avait plus de flou ça gagne pour les
Noirs parce que en fait on pousse le
pion et les blancs devraient venir
chercher le pion le plus donc perdre du
temps ben nous on va avoir à l'intérieur
on ramasse tous les pions et du coup le
bras blanc sera trop loin en fait pour
revenir donc dans cette position les
blancs doivent absolument empêcher les
échanges de pièces mineures
et essayer de bloquer de bloquer les
Noirs quoi
donc
ça va être
ça va être nul tout ça
moi je pense
que les parties avancent
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
j'ai mangé la première fois la salade
à 30 ans
un peu tard ouais
j'ai perdu à Paris l'autre jour j'ai dû
manger une salade
[Musique]
j'aime vraiment pas chaque
bouchée
[Musique]
tu comprendrais je
et depuis mon enfance je peux pas manger
de salade c'est juste
c'est marrant parce que
il paraît que quand j'étais bébé
j'ai refusé j'ai dit non je veux plus de
salade et je te promets qu'elle a la
naissance de ma sœur elle va c'était
fini voilà
je regardais la partie de signe d'Europe
j'avais un fichier du coup je vérifié
donc j'y suis
on voit qu'il a joué notre ami
[Musique]
et là je vois des 8
donc on avait dit on trouvait C8 plus
malin donc c'est ça
[Musique]
et je sais plus
en fait c'est la en fait on voulait
passer par B7 pour venir en fait
alors que là du coup avec 6 ou de 5 on
peut jouer comme ça
aucun doute que c'est nul mais est-ce
que tu es sûr c'est qu'il va jouer
après normalement eux ils savent gagner
Torfou mais par contre tu sais que fou
cavalier
[Musique]
mais juste on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait des réseaux avec le fou qui
pouvait arriver
tu te rappelles
et du coup après l'ordinateur il n'aime
pas du tout mon coup de 5
sans doute mieux
ou quelque part
et comment est-ce que je peux continuer
du coup c'est comme tout à l'heure
peut-être faut descendre
ça va vraiment faire nul à rognon c'est
sûr
et prends achète c'était quoi tout à
l'heure on a regardé on revient qui est
C4
[Musique]
et là maintenant je peux jouer
mais c'est plus malin d'avoir fait la
main avec le 5 plutôt que à 5 je
contrôle le décès direct et
et d'ailleurs peut-être que tu devais
jouer trois plus deux fois trois dans
cette ville
et si tu pars trop loin je fais froid
c'est 5 fois 5 et F6 des 7 on l'a vu on
avait les noms de sa cavalier donc tu
montes le roi
OK
donc 3 D7
20 c'est que tu as pas de moyens roi des
quatre et qui est ici
que j'ai pas vraiment de menace mais je
veux jouer genre fou c'est 6 ou 8
c'est nul toujours à la caméra ouais ça
se voit que il sait que c'est
même Google
[Musique]
il est là
mais qui est mère on dirait on dirait
pas aussi qu'il a dit ça 18 ans non tu
le vois il fait un peu il fait un peu
plus il est costaud quoi
il est costaud
[Musique]
ma fille m'a pas demandé depuis qu'elle
est rentrée
tout le monde en a mangé
en fait les deux sont pas très
intéressantes dans le sens où ça m'a
l'air nul nul nul et l'autre
il a réussi à centraliser mille Pione 5
ça va être nul assez facile
ment
est-ce que tu peux
pas incroyable les parties ouais c'est
un peu moins bien quand je suis là déjà
j'ai la poisse en général
[Musique]
tout de suite
parce que à 5 j'ai été 6 ou pas
je commence à non c'est pas si simple
mais si tu fais roi des 5 à 5 c'est quoi
ton plan
en fait
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que tu veux pas
tu vas réussir
mais il faut faire marcher ou alors
peut-être que tu fais quand il fait à 4
quand il fait à 5 tu reviens avec ton C4
après tu as aussi le cas de figure tu
peux jouer hyperactif et à un moment tu
fais kb5 et 3 on reprend G7 et c'est
nuls facile
ça c'est dans les rêves un peu
encore quelques petits trucs
mais
je suis avec cette belle cadence on a le
temps de le voir venir
en théorie il faudrait que je commence à
analyser la partie de Carona
on voit la caméra donc là vous avez
devant les yeux c'est pas Prague c'est
comme ça ça me permet de pouvoir suivre
les deux parties qui peuvent y aller il
a joué
tout à l'heure
finalement on a opté pourquoi
[Musique]
7 et puis ça permet de contrôler la case
des 7 et puis de sortir le roi quoi
[Musique]
gagnant mais c'était pas si simple en
pratique tu vois il a posé quelques
petits problèmes ouais ouais ouais non
mais c'est juste gagné en théorique mais
ouais il a posé il défend
[Musique]
u
d'avoir 17
[Musique]
qui va cette année il va sur 18
et je crois que Kemar c'est pareil
c'est fort hein
pas non plus bon
ce petit rajout d'une heure là qui fait
qu'un plaisir ça fait c'est parti un
terminal hier on a streaming
il a arrêté non
mais je me vengerai je me vengerai parce
que il y a un autre jour c'est moi qui
ai préparé
et il débrouillera
je suis en train de regarder il y a eu
la partie un peu rare de Helline dans le
tournoi B ouais
et là je vois dans la base
vite perd avec les Blancs contre Jeannot
le riff du coup
elle a joué une nouveauté arrive elle
est où
[Musique]
normalement tu fais cahier des 7 pour
jouer à 5 d'ailleurs il y a une partie
fd7 la partie regarde tu as l'impression
que c'est des amateurs qu'elle est fd7
qui est bien
[Musique]
après je joue ça qu'aucune des deux
couleurs c'est une raison de ne pas
connaître
elle a du mal à vraiment ces pièces avec
les Blancs
pas simple
elle est complètement absurde
attention quand même
venir ici alors qu'il y a eu des coups
de jouets
et 5 c'est le coup qu'on disait trois et
comme ça on contrôle la case des 7 donc
on menace de revenir avec le roi en 17
donc là du coup on peut imaginer un coup
on apprend ça à 3 on a pensé à un coup
de fou aussi en A3
vraiment vouloir manger le pion par ce
que le roi blanc s'active et il y a des
idées de matelas donc roi E3 peut-être
plutôt juste trois
et essayer de
changer un peu
d'activer le roi
[Musique]
et du coup comment est-ce qu'on continue
parce que si on bouge le roi il y a 5
qui a l'air assez chiant quand même
on peut revenir avec 3 C4 j'ai pas
vérifié
[Musique]
qui a l'air
en plus il a le temps oui il a 22
minutes à la pendule le running direct
5 heures de jeu et on est qu'au début
voilà les parties vont se terminer il
reste plus que plus que deux parties
ici dans cette position
G4
OK
puis on prend roi des 5 et après il fait
qu'il y a F5 et E3
va chercher le pion G4 et il va chercher
le roi
son idée ouais c'est que il veut
simplifier le plus possible la pause
c'est pas non plus complètement absurde
juste jamais nous on fait G4 ça a aucun
sens non j'ai quatre
j'ai quatre je le fais pas
et maintenant c'est qu'il faut revenir
avec le roi mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas si simple
après j'ai 4 ça a beaucoup de sens ça
fait sens en fait
ça fait sens parce que dans l'idée ici
même que tu vois
pour moi c'était plus logique donc à 5
on va C4 à mon avis
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce que tu penses d'un coup débile
du style roi des 8
l'idée en fait c'est d'essayer de
d'empêcher tous les cavaliers F5 et
essayer de placer un pion vers à 3 quoi
un jour peut-être parfois
le meilleur coup ouais ça a l'air un peu
contre instinctif mais
le problème c'est qu'elle a surtout en
l'air
parce que l'idée c'est que souvent en
fait quand on voit imaginons genre sur
A5
[Musique]
qui avait lieu trois
là j'aurai le temps de revenir avec le
roi dans le carré à chaque fois
[Musique]
OK
pas grand chose en fait
j'ai l'impression pour
pour Harmonia ici
ça revient qui joue pour pour le gain
et dans l'autre il y a des coupes ben
non parce qu'on va la position il
redescend
entre 7h et 7h30 je vais te laisser
franchement ok c'est quoi le pourcentage
qui est une partie décisive dans les
deux qui restent je pense que très
faible la première il regarde je pense
que c'est
clairement enfin c'est clair que c'est
ça la Régale la deuxième il faut être à
peu près ici mais bon Kemer a l'air
quand même la confiance la jauge j'ai
confiance aussi
Mathieu aient confiant
je suis confiant
un truc un peu similaire
pour
je peux pas faire faire comme exercice
en grand OUI
[Musique]
trois et quatre du coup je la fourchette
là c'est voilà on a déjà dit ça
pas grand chose il y a pas de coup droit
possible ou ce cavalier
je pense que c'est ça va être nul les
deux je pense sincèrement
ça m'a l'air complètement
j'aime pas trop ce qu'on peut tenter ça
se passe bien aujourd'hui ben oui
tranquille il y a pas eu trop de parties
intéressante d'avoir des Prague était
intéressante
est-ce que tu as vu ma partie que j'ai
analysé sur stock fish récente non
elle marche bien pour une fois ouais
vas-y envoie
tu es un peu de temps à la partie drôle
c'est un chaos atomique c'est les coups
ont aucun sens c'est plus des échecs
du coup c'était vachement bien
le conseil de regarder n'hésite pas à
partager
on la trouve sur Blitz
souvent c'est plutôt libres en ce moment
c'est
est-ce qu'on peut proposer de nulle
direct
ok te dire que je dois faire une vidéo
de ça aujourd'hui
et ça a l'air ça a l'air simple en fait
encore plus fort que ce qu'on avait dit
comment tu passes pas
parce que
je trouvais plus où tu étais donc
j'étais en train de regarder le live
c'est validé
[Musique]
ces trois je pense
que tu veux faire
il faut compter je crois que ça marche
ça a l'air
à 3 et du coup j'ai pas trop de coups
pour attendre et je suis
je fais quoi du coup
pourquoi tu joues pas les couilles
parce que si je
[Musique]
si j'attends je progresser c'est
toujours réussir à passer par là
après je peux refaire Roissy 4 6 qui est
pas trop le schmilblick
[Musique]
je pense que
très peu de chance que ça
il y a eu des coups
je peux regarder sur roisset
[Musique]
voir la course qui est cuite
moi c'est 7 robes
[Musique]
OK
je comprends pas ce qu'il veut de moi
on va le trouver
joue
les projets 7
ok ok regardez un joli cavalier c'est le
seul moyen de gagner ici
du coup
non mais ça marche pas
bonjour
chez moi
le coup d'avant
mais je pense qu'il va la gagner en fait
lundi il a pas trouvé le G4
[Musique]
il est pas du tout
il va la gagner on était bien médisant
en pratique c'est hyper dur
mais rien franchement il est le seul
parti tu vois il a le sachant mais il a
pas du tout été inquiété avec les Noirs
et des sets
[Musique]
il faut que je fasse un coup d'attente
ici
tu peux pas jouer au roi des 6 à 4 gagne
comment
[Musique]
OK
mais pourquoi on vient de dire courage
et 5 tu as pas trouvé de plus
[Musique]
moi
je repars avec mon fou
qui a des trois fois aussi
je sais pas
roi C6 après c'est ça
mais maintenant je peux donner mon flou
compte option de pousser mon pion a le
plus possible et faire ranger 5 3G 4
pour projet 3 ça m'a l'air gagnant
pas d'idée je crois non
[Musique]
il ajoute cavalier gs5 et on a on a
Kemer qui réfléchit depuis un petit
moment
donc on a parlé de la de la fourchette
après il y a la même fionnement quand
même
et le fou
peut-être qu'il a avoir s'il a rien de
d'autre il va le jouer
mais c'est vrai que la finale elle peut
être un petit peu problématique
là j'ai pas réussi tu vois
pas jouer ça à cause de roi des 4
en fait peut-être que si je peux le
jouer quand même
tu fais du mal propre à grand chose
[Musique]
on revient ça fait pousser six alors si
tu veux faire un coup comme ça
que j'ai 5 et on va essayer de venir
défendre là
mais je sais
dans cette ligne au lieu de reviens en
arrière
encore
qui prend des 6 dans la après OK
ça ça me ferait peur
tu peux pas échanger les cavaliers non
c'est pas encore fini les deux
par exemple pour qu'elle prenne 7
vont tomber quoi
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer F6
la F6
en fait ça c'est le plus clean peut-être
parce que tu as pas le droit
oui au 60e coup pour être sûr en rajoute
encore 15 minutes
pour être sûr qu'on n'est pas assez de
temps
ça c'est nul non c'est peut-être il faut
trouver
de toute façon si il faut trouver des
coups il va les trouver je pense qui
meurt il a beaucoup de temps à la
pendule Geoffrey
c'est quoi le plus logique en fait si tu
fais F6 en maintenant il y a cavalier 4
c'est à part aussi celle qui est assez 5
donc c'est peut-être plus simple je vois
on se place et on va essayer de prendre
un peu les cases avec nos pièces
tu as vu un coup
avec quelques coups de retard
ouais il a laissé le roi faire le tour
de l'échiquier ouais ouais du coup
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
peut-être que tu peux essayer un jour
d'aller bouffer le pion et comme tu
disais tout à l'heure hein
et
donc on dit tout à l'heure du coup le
cahier cette cavaliers c'est 5 parce que
ça
ça change quelque chose
alors
il s'est dit dans cette ligne
plus loin
là je mets 4 un petit peu
je réussir à faire ça ça quoi c'est
pas je trouve pas de coup pour les
blancs
quand même
je peux peut-être même gagner maintenant
en fait il fallait que tu ailles en
fuite avec le fond peut-être
mieux
c'est logique de fin de venir
s'éloigner un peu pour éviter tous les
échecs
je peux pas faire
non ça va ça va être trop chaud
[Musique]
mais j'y crois pas trop
c'est un peu et la jauge non plus
OK
[Musique]
on a dit quoi là
et détront à l'année
[Musique]
ok c'est 6 à 4 il te manque un temps
c'est quand même c'est quand même ultra
compliqué
ils sont quand même forts
et un peu un ordi des fois etc on a du
mal à comprendre avant tout ce qui se
passe et eux te dis qui doivent jouer
trouver des coups et c'est dur
cette finale a quand même compliqué
aussi
beaucoup de temps à la pendule et puis
le 5 coups avant le rajouter
on a hâte de ce petit rajout de temps ah
oui
ça c'est clair
pas de suite
donc Prague ils ont encore 15 fois à
faire dans le rajout de temps
donc en tout cas je décale bon ou
logique c'est quand même
c'est normal c'est normal de calculer
aussi H4 c'est manger avec l'Europe pour
pousser les champs plus tard quoi
on commence à être fatigué 5h30 qu'on
est là
ça va un peu mieux que tout à l'heure
je t'ai dit qu'à 7h30 je partais en plus
il faut qu'il se trompe avant
que Mathieu pars
je regarde
il prend son temps pour être bien sûr
que
ça me perturbe de voir un docteur à
droite
ça
y est plus rien
du coup
je pense qu'il y a pas grand chose à
faire
enfin j'ai apprécié c'est quand même
pas moyen de passer
et du coup après j'ai quatre questions
puis après eux aussi
[Musique]
5h30 de jeu
pas simple et
calcule aussi et qui a plus beaucoup de
temps la pendule qui est mort qui a plus
que 9 minutes
pour jouer 15 coups
j'aime bien le F6 sinon
ça devrait faire mais F6 tu forces la
finale
qu'on pensait proche de l'égalité
peut-être que lui ça lui plaît pas c'est
une
quand il pense qu'il peut manger parfait
parfait direct
alors on l'a dit
on a parlé de ça c'est quoi là
[Musique]
je peux pas faire trop n'importe quoi
un petit peu plus quand même
[Musique]
mais
possible donc du coup là il s'est enlevé
de la fourchette quand même
c'est pas sûr Kevin m'a pas répondu si
je la faisais mais j'ai vu qu'il était
live
je t'appelle pas tout
tu veux que je t'appelle non non
il a
jouécape et donc c'est la banque on
avait dit tout à l'heure avec moi j'ai 5
ans
je suis peut-être dans la merde il a
trouvé G4 si c'était posé la question
donc là il faut pas jouer ce qu'on a dit
alors
c'est le même truc la même ligne qu'on a
donné tout à l'heure
j'arrive
dans quel sens
ok on va voir en tout cas
6 je pense qu'il a calculé ça longtemps
et si j'attends pas
22 minutes pour jouer x 8 c'est une
heure quand même
j'ai l'impression
tu peux pas bouger ton cavalier vraiment
tu peux pas vraiment bouger ton gros
ton fou a pas de bonne case
toujours plus et
ici ton roi il est quand même loin donc
là
je m'en fous
encore
mais bon c'est quand même je mange le
pion dans la condition
[Musique]
j'attends que tu joues un coup
et
[Musique]
du coup on rigole
qui revient dans la position qu'on a
fait avant c'était la même position sauf
qu'il a fait je pense à 4 intermédiaire
c'est quoi l'idée
mais du coup il faut que je roep 6
donc 8
encore
[Musique]
je comprends pas
pourquoi
[Musique]
pas du tout
parce que tu fais quoi en fait
[Musique]
on vient en B6 mais tu progresses pas
quoi
mais c'est
marrantes pas donc si jamais j'arrive à
bloquer ça en fait
[Musique]
du coup
si tu devais parier
tu paries
la manœuvre là il crois G6
limite je viens te dire nul c'est dans
sa logique
c'est un petit peu dur de voir comment
on peut progresser on va fixer trois on
va D5
pour les Noirs
maintenant en fait parce que je peux pas
bouger mon pion
des menaces de ça
pardon et toi tu peux faire wave 5
si le roi par trop loin tu bouges le
pion
ouais ouais
mais ok peut-être fou ces trois juste
et propose nul
ou c'est trois voilà
il faut jouer un coup
le
[Musique]
pas grand chose parce que du coup je
ferai encore roi au 5 il a pas compris
qu'il devait jouer avec le fou sur la
diagonale A3 F8 monter le roi il avait
déjà pas facile bien sûr extrêmement
difficile
[Musique]
et c'est déjà pas mal
c'est un ordinateur que tu n'as pas la
maison que tu utilises des Cloud
elle a un partenariat avec Microsoft et
du coup ils ont accès
à Microsoft azur
et du coup tu as des cloud hyper fort
échec
s on va bouger le cas le roi du coup
non
ok je peux encore manger ici mais après
le temps sera abandonné
peut-être qu'on roi des cinq
fois F2
il y a un problème
mais il va la tourner ça peut se craquer
ça
ça peut craquer tu vois la position
blanche elle tient vraiment sur un fil
parce que là c'est sur noir 2 jouet mais
c'est tout blanc de jouer ça pourrait
être un peu problématique non
ici ça irait encore pour les blancs
ça pourrait être quasiment mais je peux
toujours faire échec et revenir en fait
et peut-être juste fait caca
qui a gagné avec les pièces blanches
contre vent de Forest
c'est la seule partie pour l'instant
donc il y a aussi il y a aussi bien sûr
il Prague qui est pas encore terminé
d'ailleurs ça a joué
il a joué H4
il reste plus que 7 buts à la pendule
pour pour
7 minutes pour jouer pour le 14 coups
pour arriver au centième de dernier
ajout de tente 15 minutes
et
c'est absurde que tu es pas la mise à
jour automatique des
je pense que je bug de ouf non mais ça
je l'ai
mais ça bug c'est
genre
et ce qu'on a réussi à faire quelque
chose je crois pas
et je me lâche toujours échec c'est je
veux ma position entre les rois
maintenant ça c'est un peu retourné
qu'il a eu des chances de gains je
voulais juste voir comme s'il valait
un coup dans mon
qui a été joué
oh là là le blender
ah non c'est plus malin
parce que maintenant le roi des 4 qui
prend des 6 5 et cavaliers
non non
là on avait dit Kaye C4 à cause de x 8
parce qu'il y a que H4 comme cours
[Musique]
parce que si tu me fais 5 et kf5
j'attaque ok du coup il force faut
prendre des six
très facile
d'ailleurs je suis pas sûr un mille pour
cent mais
après mon pire il y avait recette
mais oui c'est peut-être plus clean
c'est peut-être très bien joué peut-être
que c'est plus simple
bien joué
[Musique]
est-ce que je peux aller peut-être en F4
du coup
[Musique]
et du coup roi F4 ce que je dois pas
jouer avec 6
qui est 4 4 6
du coup
je sais pas
malheureusement je sais pas quel est le
plus malin
F6
qui achète G5
mais bon
ça devrait faire
il a joué le roi des quatre
cinq comme tu disais donc et si G4 F6
donc il va prendre en D6 et jouer ouais
il a pris des six
pour empêcher un F5
mais
on n'y croit pas trop F6
il y a pas de mauvais coup en fait c'est
juste une il faut juste un moment faire
G5 quand le cavalier partira et à rognon
du coup donc ça va maintenant
assez sympa qui empêche
il s'est passé quoi
je ne sais pas
en gros Fighter avec les blancs mais un
peu naïf vraiment
bien conso
noir et Prague dananda noir donc c'est
normal
ok je pars au prochain coup
ça marche
là il va pas il va passer une demi-heure
mais du coup à demain
ma mère demain
allez ciao tout le monde et puis à
demain
je vais vous mettre l'autre vu du coup
celle-là non c'est pas celle-là que je
voulais mais pas mal du coup
je pense je vais garder celle-là avec
avec la caméra en grand comme ça autant
vous voyez la l'expression un peu des
joueurs je vais virer ça aussi voilà
et puis et puis du coup on est tout seul
donc oui on disait un roi des quatre
rois bouge peut-être
on a l'impression quand même que que les
Blancs s'en sortent s'en sortent pas mal
mais en fait le pion et le cavalier
contrôle toutes les cases des Noirs en
fait
et du coup droit un peu plus activer
donc pendant ce temps là on va essayer
d'aller partir à manger de lui
et après éventuellement aller manger lui
pendant que noir donc pas grand chose à
faire donc cette partie qui risque de
faire un nul je pense
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une expression belge pas
de métal ça c'est marrant j'ai un pote
qui habite là-bas à chaque fois une
boîte tracasse tracasse et en France tu
utilises pas tracasse
en Belgique qu'on utilise ça une
personne
donc croise a été joué et là du coup on
va ramener
tout à l'heure par Mathieu
mais là on va juste ramener le roi et
puis
mais ça a l'air d'être nul assez
facile celle-là
ouais solidaire merci merci polir
ça c'est marrant comme expression
tout va bien
[Musique]
ok on va pousser 8 aussi et attendre
avoir un peu ce qui se passe vous voyez
que on peut pousser des pions mais au
final le cavalier bougera plus
et
cavaler ici ben je vais attendre un roi
là voilà et normalement cette partie qui
devrait faire un nul je pense
sincèrement sous peu la cavalier G4
ouais 5
je pense qu'il va le voir 5
après voilà je mets un peu parce que bah
écoute
il a le droit de la jouer même si les
chances de gagner sont assez seront
minimes
est-ce que j'ai donc c'est pas nul
direct
calculer est-ce que j'ai 5 h 5G 4 et je
peux aller manger le pion
si je G5 il me laisse manger là aussi il
mange ça c'est nul sans
ce qu'on va d'abord
ça échec
je pensais à ça à essayer de venir
pas de moyens je peux sacrifier mais
après je suis pas sûr qu'on peut avancer
parce que le foot pour bien la case
blanche
on va voir
ton courage de carénage de pardon
à côté parce que ça ça joue pas on a
cavalé des cinq ça part rejouer depuis
pour moi elle est elle est assez claire
je vois pas je vois pas du tout caméra
ici je pense que même moi je pourrais la
faire mieux c'est pour
pour vous imaginer un petit peu
la facilité du truc par contre il a dit
aronial bah ça a été pendant très
longtemps une partie hyper compliqué
complexe et là du coup depuis deux trois
coups et ben on a l'impression que la
partie c'est vraiment aplani et que ça
va être nul à c'est tranquille
on commence on continue ça
donc le but je pense qu'ici à Prague va
jouer à G4 G5 peut-être
G4 cavalier F3 progresser un petit peu
on ne peut pas ici manger le cavalier
attention c'est une finale qui qui
serait sans doute gagner pour pour les
blancs donc G4 voilà qui avait la
ramener le roi c'est le plan de Prague
mais du coup moi j'aime bien j'ai ça
H6 mon plan ça va être foulard fou prend
son cavalier
même un plan très très simple qui est ça
ça peut-être plus pour par couper court
à toute à tout tester
et du coup j'ai 5 mains peut-être le
plus simple et plus efficace voyez j'ai
5 il prend bah juste nul gros
s'il fait H5 moi je fais chez 4 puis je
fais partie manger à manger ici
et sur G4 intermédiaire je vais là s'il
mange c'est nul si il pousse voilà et
justement à ramener le fou pour manger à
chaque fois en fait c'est nul
extrêmement facilement celle-là
et là c'est il a trouvé
il a trouvé la solution il va le jouer
je pense
ça va faire nul assez facilement ici
c'est la partie de Prague contre Kemer
donc pral qui est parti se promener
s'assure de
bien terminer la partie
de l'autre côté on a encore irrigué
derrière la caméra qui se promener je
crois que c'était lui
et cette pollution elle est juste
complètement nulle avec le cavalier qui
est le pion qui contrôle les gaz du roi
et donc le roi Nantes pourra plus du
tout venir en aide il y a eu à 4 mais le
roi est dans le carré qu'à priori après
roi des quatre ça devrait réussir à
faire nul
ramener le roi ici ça devrait ça devrait
faire mieux
je pense qu'on va assister à deux belles
nulles
donc que voyage 2 ici est-ce qu'il va
nous loger 5
en face c'était avant
[Rires]
de venir c'est ça
empêche les parties les finales sont
quand même assez tiens j'ai vu sur une
autre caméra
aronium faire nul père et la main avec
irrigues et
[Musique]
c'est quand même plutôt les noirs avec
le fou qui va venir ici etc même ici
mais cette position est quand même
complètement nulle en fait c'est bon
pourront pas gagner parce que
je vais mettre mon four ici défendre le
pion et pour venir gagner avec les
parents il faudra venir manger si tu
veux depuis 1 à 3 quoi et si tu manges
depuis 1 3 moi on va venir ici manger là
en fait c'est juste impossible quoi
les deux les SS enfin c'est nul quoi et
personne peut essayer en fait
à la caméra bah ce qui je peux gagner
c'est clairement c'est clairement les
blancs c'est Prague on a plus que cette
partie là du coup
il a retroussé 8 c'est dommage qu'il est
pas joué le petit G5 là j'ai 5 c'était
vraiment le coup le coussin
et
je sens que c'était nul vraiment pas
facile
facile G5
bonsoir à toi Pologne
et à demain merci à toi bonne soirée
du coup vous savez 4 je vais juste
reculer mon
échanger les pions quoi tout simplement
mais j'espère que
j'ai 5 prises reprend nul parce que ben
je sacrifié
sur H5 j'avais G4 et j'allais manger les
pions et si je joue j'ai 4 et à la place
je faisais voilà j'ai plus qu'à aller
manger le pion H5 2 fois c'était nul
donc il a vu que j'ai 4 ça va quand même
faire nul aussi
donc là il y a des
pas bouger à cause de la prise ici
j'ai 5 n'a pas l'air d'être un coup de
génie parce que le bras va venir ici et
il y a un blocus sur case blanche
je sais pas trop
encore une fois alors
vous pouvez venir après défendre
l'option de 6 sans problème
c'est nul on voit que les deux joueurs
savent que c'est nul on voit que qui est
très
très serein
on sent qu'il sait que c'est nul et
Prague qui sait aussi que c'est nul
aussi mais qui
qui cherche des trucs il se posent des
questions
mais
ça va faire nul malheureusement pour
Prague je le vois pas du tout gagner la
partie
bonne soirée humaine à bientôt
on se dit avec l'option non ça gagnera
bouge je prends je viens là
je la fais passer
ça va perdre pour toi ça fait attention
je ne sais pas
peut-être que la raison elle est simple
que il voulait peut-être est-ce que je
sens que ça fait le mieux peut-être
ça fait nul ça
j'attends
[Musique]
attention mais je pense pas que ce soit
l'intérêt de caméra de 5 sur roi F4 donc
du coup
mais c'est
pour moi pas si simple
ça va faire nul sur moi mais bon
d'ailleurs
c'est vraiment le coup qui fait nul à
chaque fois
parce que on va prendre ok au revoir
et si le pion
pousse bah je vais mettre mon four ici
et mon roi là et je vais sacrifier en
fait
si tu dis que les deux savent que c'est
nul pourquoi jouer ben les gens qui
allaient noir et ben il doit jouer les
bons coups pour faire un nul
et tant qu'il a pas démontré qu'il sait
comment faire nul ben voilà quoi et les
blancs il a une toute petite chance de
cette gagner ben il tente quoi c'est
normal quand tu as une légère chance il
faut il faut jouer quoi
et c'est le noir que tu as des montres
en fait si les Noirs trouvent comment
faire nul
et ben ça panique donc les blancs du
coup ça sort ça sur juste que ça fasse
bien nul c'est juste ça
c'est le stuff si vraiment les deux
savent que c'est pourquoi prolonger je
crois que j'ai répondu ah j'ai 5 a été
joué
dans quelques minutes
là c'est vraiment simple je vais foulard
full art voilà
c'est assez simple et voilà le foulard
et boum boum boum badaboum
d'ailleurs relais 7 je pense on va
commencer comme ça parce que vous allez
dire du coup ça laisse le blanc
cesse Laurent ici
je vais sur 4 par exemple
H5 et rencontre cavalier ben c'est nul
et donc du coup laisser le coup ici
c'est un peu mieux parce que du coup ça
force
le roi de rester entre guillemets ainsi
nous a répondu mais du coup croisé 7
maintenant il va jouer ça et si le roi
blanc reste par exemple ça là bien sûr
il va pas faire pour prendre ici parce
que parce qu'on apprend et là on regarde
la partie avec par contre on va jouer
fou là
F5 qui puisse arriver quand même
qui pourrait mettre la pression
mais du coup si je joue pas
ici je veux prendre le fou
le Caval doit rester ici
et le roi doit rester là en fait je peux
faire ça mais moi je vais on va attendre
quoi et sur un cavalier 5
parce que les pions bah ils vont
s'échanger quoi donc là on est au 50e
coups il y a encore quatre coups avant
d'arriver
on rajoute tant au dernier résultat de
15 minutes chacun mais je pense qu'on
n'y arrivera pas enfin je pense que ils
vont pas être en tout cas utiliser leur
rajoutant parce que
parce que ça m'a l'air d'être nul très
très très facile
6h01 c'est la durée du stream patoche et
on a commencé quand ouais ça a duré de
la partie aussi parce que du coup on a
commencé le stream en début de partie
donc
voilà donc tac Yuk cavalier F3
et il va jouer
[Musique]
tout fait nul
ça va être
oui elle cache oui
cavalier D4 ou des 7
et ça va être nul
ça va être nul
va y aller on a l'impression que
[Musique]
c'est nul et qu'il attend la proposition
de nul
alors si on a eu on a eu Mathieu
Mathieu cornette pendant presque 6
heures
et puis il est parti
donc je termine tout seul mais demain on
aura on aura de nouveau Mathieu demain
voilà donc là ça tourne sans position ça
tourne roi F3
le roi doit rester ici
là où là parce que sinon le pion sera
perdu si le cavalier bouge ben je le
sens
qui va tenter des choses
car comment je fais nul
[Musique]
je vais là
des petites choses quand même
tac ça bug encore
[Musique]
et
qui avait les problèmes
je pense que si je joue n'importe quel
coup ça va faire nul ils empêchent
ça ne peut pas gagner ça
ne peut pas gagner il y a cette échelle
si le roi part et ben il y aura poussé
vite
le roi de revenir défendre depuis qu'on
peut imaginer
plus tard
on pourra pas mettre le flou sur une de
ces cases en fait
sur le cavalle tout par exemple ça pour
venir ici il y aura ça menace qui
contrôle la case et en plus qui me
laisse échec et qu'elle va les prendre
ici
les deux joueurs ont le même âge à peu
près 17 ans 18 ans
les joueurs qui sont en troisième coup
donc ils ont eu un rajout de temps de 15
minutes chacun pour terminer la partie
qui gagnerait pour les blancs du coup
voilà cavaler décide de jouer fou des 5
fossil va être joué
et surtout si
voilà j'empêche ça j'appelle ça
donc sur
échec encore je pense
juste échec
si le roi par ici je reviens ici
attaquer le four par là je fais ça et là
c'est une nulle qui va avoir là dans
trois coups un maximum je pense on a la
nul
parce que je vois pas ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut faire
ici
[Musique]
c'est complètement nul vous voyez si le
cavalier des blancs bougent en fait
bon par exemple on peut imaginer 5 c'est
bon
au revoir
si tu fais
échec là je peux toujours reculer mais
en fait tu menaces rien moi bouge pas et
le cavalier bouge pas je me suis fou
qui vraiment n'avance pas quoi
les joueurs qui veulent pas se quitter
[Musique]
par le partage du point
G7
bah en fait quelle heure pose pas nul
parce que
c'est pas lui proposer en fait
ce serait un peu mal vu de sa part pour
que
sachant que c'est lui qui dépend en fait
lui c'est lui qui mène plus c'est plutôt
à lui si vous voulez de d'aller jusqu'au
bout et te proposer
mais c'est pas vraiment à quelle heure
vous allez je pense que
c'est
assez mal vu de sa part
oui bon de toute façon là il essaye des
choses donc là il y a une cavalier
ça perdrait
un petit peu
non il risque pas d'énergie parce que
c'est la fin de la partie enfin c'est la
fin de la de la partie là
ça a pas durer très longtemps il a
raison de tenter s'il pense qu'il a une
puissance de gain il a raison de la
jouer après là il va pas la jouer une
heure de plus hein
sur la fin de la partie
vraiment sur la fin
mais la raison de la jouer ainsi à ce
niveau-là gagne une partie c'est
tellement dur dès que tu as 1800 de
pouvoir gagner il faut la saisir
il faut la saisir et essayer de
essayer d'y aller
donc
is3f6 qu'est-ce qu'il va faire là
s'il laisse comme ça il va manger
il bouge le cavalier et je le vois là
pour essayer d'aller sacrifier le fou
et
c'est assez simple en fait ça c'est un
peu
une colonne ouais ouais il se passe rien
mentalement c'est pas trop difficile de
jouer les blancs
donc il a raison de la jouer un petit
peu et torture un peu l'adversaire
même si à zéro risque
correspondant sur place oui oui tu peux
peut-être
il y a plus de sens que ce soit ça
plutôt que
plutôt que ça arrive en tant que en tant
que joueur
parce que
c'est pas le niveau pour faire pour moi
même le challenger j'ai pas le niveau
c'est trop dur en plus ils prennent que
des joueurs que des jeunes joueurs
talentueux
imaginons OK
et du coup
tu aurais pu
dis rien pour l'instant mais peut-être
un jour
on verra
[Musique]
ttana et tout le monde
ici c'est cool quoi
ça me prend
en allemand
papa il y a
tac tac elle est bonne la paillarde en
Espagne
c'est le fou prend le cavalier
puis on prend
le fou et le roi
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce que tu as
écrit de l'étude mais
j'ai bien compris tu te demandais si
prise le pion pouce mais je le rattrape
c'est nul en fait
si j'ai bien compris c'est ça
qui annule moi presque
il y a une nul à nul
argentin oui argentin
l'espagnol mais c'est différent en fait
par exemple pour dire je sais pas moi
un mot par exemple
je m'appelle on dit mais d'accord
ça fait méchamment les doubles l il fait
chaud il y a beaucoup de mots comme ça
et en fait du coup tu as la fonction qui
chante en fait quand il parle par
rapport à leur accent moi j'aime bien
l'accent argentin je trouve qu'il est il
est sympa
je vous dis
je suis resté pas parce que quand même
pas avant je suis resté
quatre cinq mois je sais plus comme ça
merci beaucoup
espagnol ouais
il est vraiment sympa
non pas tout n'importe quoi
c'est pas du tout parce qu'il reprend je
regarde et je vais venir manger ton
plongée cavalier contre pionche ça va
gagner
facile d'ailleurs mais charmante
ça veut dire je m'appelle en argentin
et même en fait toute une différence
parce que il convient en fait
différemment
donc si vraiment tu apprends l'espagnol
à l'école le Castillon vraiment à
l'école il y a pas beaucoup d'expérience
et que tu pars directement en Argentine
tu vas rien comprendre
et c'est vachement différent
pour partir à la base il faut quand même
bien parler quoi parce que c'est quand
même c'est
ça cool
[Musique]
je sais plus
je l'ai su Kamel très bien merci
c'est ça c'est ça
avec les mains
allons-y chantant
si tu le dis tu le dis pas alors tu me
chantes une chanson en allemand
d'ailleurs en parlant vous voyez mais
quelle heure il est allemand
qui est mort il est allemand
voilà c'est nul très facile maintenant
encore qu'il fasse nul ils vont gueuler
le plaisir à ces petits jeunes
donc pas là
avec moi
sur ce stream mais je le dirai pas mais
j'aurais dit autre chose
[Musique]
on pratique fait qui durait le plaisir
il veut pas craquer
de ne pas faire de ne pas craquer
donc si jamais on veut pas marcher la
règle 50 coups il faut arriver jusqu'au
106 donc encore
aussi voilà donc là il va refaire je
pense
ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
un coup un son de clou
il craque pas le premier c'est tout pour
faites moi qui vais faire le premier en
vrai là
c'est très très mal
[Musique]
parti
personne n'est pas non car c'est un
épaule il y avait vraiment de quoi jouer
quoi là il y a il y a rien à jouer là
il y a rien à jouer
ça
fait longtemps que je dis que ça va
fermer le maintenant là
et ça fait pas nul
donc
maintenant qu'elle me la fin mais ça
devrait être nul quand même
prochainement
pour se répéter ouais après je sais pas
si vraiment il compte ça
c'est compliqué de compter ça avec lui
cavaliers qui ont bougé
[Musique]
il leur reste beaucoup de temps à la
pendule
arania
je pourrais vous le mettre en fait je
pense que c'est pas encore ajusté
moi je vois une minute trente chez gamer
et 8 chez Prague il y a 15 minutes de
rajout donc en fait ils ont beaucoup de
temps ils ont beaucoup de temps tous les
deux
bref ça a été joué
mon chat non parce que
[Musique]
ma copine est rentrée à la maison tout à
l'heure son voyage
et du coup le chat est occupé voilà en
fait le chat est
il a besoin d'une présence humaine et si
à personne avec lui
c'est le drame
c'est le drame donc là du coup je suis
sauvé
va dire en ce moment les Argentins santé
en anglais ouais c'est ça
d'ailleurs moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis en
Argentine
et je te garantir quand ils ont gagné la
Coupe du Monde et ben c'était
en plus j'ai pris des paris de partout
le moral moi je suis pas spécialement
foot de base par contre je suis très
pari quoi
j'ai pas accepté que mes potes me
battent comme ça et derrière
voir si
ils sont très provocateurs quand même
l'argent
et blanc tentes de faire craquer les
Noirs oui il joue un peu étant de se
faire craquer mais bon
je l'entends
tu vois j'ai parlé un peu trop vite je
crois
pour 4 allez mange moi ce pion on en
parle plus c'est manger
et ça a fait nul direct ou est-ce qu'ils
vont aller jusqu'au roi contre roi
non ça c'est nul
sauvé par le gong donc les gars on a eu
des belles parties aujourd'hui notamment
la partie de Caravana qui a battu en
forêt je vais vous montrer le petit le
petit les résultats en direct regarder
voir si ça a été mis à jour voilà tout a
été mis à jour on a rapport qui a fait
nul contre saut on a car voilà qui a
fait une super partie contre one forest
on a goûtage qui a fait une nulle contre
McDo slow contre guéri qu'on a Carlson
qui était nul assez rapide contre Ding
ma Prague qui vient de faire nul à
l'instant là contre Kemer et
erikasi contre aronium avec une finale
hyper hyper hyper complexe donc ça a
fait nul je pourrais vous montrer